Excellent. Ready? Boom. All right, we're lot. Hello John. What's up man?
How are you Joe? How you doing? Thanks for doing this. I really appreciate it.
Thanks a lot for having me, man. It's great.
I heard you on media podcasts and uh, it blew my mind. I mean, I,
I could not believe, let's just let everybody know what this is about.
You were a game warden or you are a game warden, right?
And what that normally entails is like, you know,
you find a guy and he's got three trout when he's only supposed to have two.
It's normal stuff like catchy catching people doing something they're not
supposed to. Just make sure people follow the rules. Right.
Along the way,
you guys started discovering these illegal grow ops where cartels were growing
marijuana and you turn from being a regular game warden to essentially,
well, why don't you let us know how it worked out? Yeah, Joe, it was,
it was a crazy journey because you don't think of game wardens doing the type of
work we were doing when it come to the trespass grows in the cartel issue.
You know? And what do everybody think? They think game warns,
check fishing licenses, check your deer tag or elk tag. Look for too many,
you know, animals poaching, spotlighting. And honestly, when I started the job,
I got hired back in 1992. That's what I dreamed of doing. You know,
I grew up hunting and fishing and I got my a hundred safety certificate with
dad's help at nine years old. So I was all in the woods, you know,
the woods are my church. I just loved it. It cause three generations of family.
My grandfather's career, Navy, my dad, you know, as an army guy and you know,
we just had conservation in our family, you know, um, for generations.
So I got the job, did it, and I did all the traditional stuff to start.
We came down here to Southern California to start my career in Riverside County.
So it was just over the Hill, you know, from,
from LA here and working all the traditional stuff, fishing regulations,
night hunting, you know,
working deer openers is really cool to be a deer Hunter for all those years.
And then actually go, you know,
talk to guys on the other side and see all the good guys out there and some
problems. Um, and then in, uh, 1995,
I got to go back home towards the Silicon Valley.
That's where I'm originally from. Born and raised, so live in the suburbs,
kind of the Foothill areas of the Silicon Valley South, the San Jose there.
And in 2004, I F I stumbled into my first,
uh, you know, cartel, what we call a trespass marijuana grow site and you know,
to specify this stuff now, now that we're regulating, you know,
the last couple of years here in California,
these are not sanctioned marijuana sites.
This isn't the legitimate industry that's doing it by the numbers and trying to,
this is always illegal. Uh, these are always here, you know, on public lands,
destroying our environmental waterways and our wildlife and on private land as
well. And on that situation.
I had a good friend of mine that I grew up with on that was doing his master's
thesis at San Jose state university, both of our Alma mater on steelhead trout,
endangered species, red legged, yellow legged frog,
and all the aquatics in these two creeks.
And this was right below Henry COE state park where I really met my first game
or, and
that was an inspiration to get the job. So these waterways are really sensitive,
headwaters coming down through this stretch for like three miles.
All these endangered species in it, black tail, deer, you know,
all these other great animals we like as conservationists,
they're thriving on this Creek. And he called me one day in April and said,
Hey John, this is weird.
One of my two creeks is bone dry and all the fish,
the steelhead fry are dead. You know, everything living on this Creek is dead.
There's a bunch of like debris and plastic lining and it looks like camping
stuff that's down at the bottom of where this Creek feeds out.
So I get them in the truck and I figured, I'm thinking, okay,
someone's diverting water up there.
It's probably a ranch or Nina for cattle operation, whatever.
We only top of the Hill joke and we start the hike down and I'm by myself,
you know, I got my, my got my rifle, got my gear, don't have any radio coverage,
don't have any cell phone coverage. I have an unarmed civilian,
my partner biologists with me.
And we're expecting to find something very predictable that I'd seen up to that
point. And that would've been a normal water diversion.
And when we found the water source in a beautiful Canyon,
I mean crystal clear water, trout Creek, the whole nine, start hiking down it,
following this. Uh, we see the dam,
we see the waterline go about a hundred yards down this beautiful little grand
Canyon like Creek. And there's much marijuana plants and they're short.
Cause it's early in the season, they're only about two feet tall.
And we see two growers and they're not the growers on tip, you know,
that I would have suspected these guys are, you know, they got rifles,
they got handguns,
they got knives and they're kind of cruising work in their plants coming toward
us. And that was that Oh shit moment. You know,
if something crazy goes down right now and I got no backup,
I got a civilian with me. These guys are armed.
They're not your typical poacher that I've ever encountered. And um,
we didn't get seen. We kinda hit out, you know, he's a Hunter. I'm a Hunter.
We stayed, you know, using our stocking and Stan to the Creek bank and just,
just watch as these guys work their plantation and went on up the Hill and I
looked at this and went, what did we just walk into? This is crazy. Um,
we got out safely and that's when I started to bring in other agencies,
narcotic groups, task forces, the Sheriff's office, um, met, you know,
started to learn other agencies in my area. This is really on in the game.
What did you guys do about that one? Grow up like when you found it,
like how did, how did they resolve that? Well,
we got a team together as fast as we could safely and usually it takes a couple
of weeks and I want to say within a month we were back there.
Now the interesting part was game warns aren't known for doing this type of
work. Just like you said at the start, right? So they're like, well,
you guys know the area, you went in there, help us find it,
get us into the area, but we're going to lead the raid and we'll,
so of course this is your jurisdiction. We don't normally do this type of stuff.
So, uh, so go for it. So we were the bird dogs.
We kinda guided them into the area. We had like 20, 30 officers. We, uh,
kind of led them down to the Canyon, got 'em in there safely. Um, we,
the two growers, we spoke to them, they didn't get caught that day. They,
they ran down the Canyon. Nobody pursued, some of us wanted to,
obviously because of the environmental damages.
But the biggest thing that changed the game for me that day was seeing the
environmental damage. So that was a 7,000 plant garden.
And at the time we didn't know about these ban and toxic substances,
these insecticides Carbofuran that they're bringing up from Tijuana and,
and transporting actually smuggling from cross the border to put on these plants
to keep everything living off of it, not to impact their cash crop.
And that was out there in some extent, but it was so early.
We weren't really aware of the level of toxicity to this stuff and how damaging
it is. Um, so it was all new, but we eradicated that, that garden.
And then when we were done eradicating it, we had all this mess in the Creek,
right? We had camp trash, we had fertilizers, pollutants, propane tanks,
um, all over in this beautiful channel that's now dry cause it's been diverted.
Unbeknownst to us, all that water was totally poisoned,
that they were diverting to water the plants. That's why that Creek was so dry.
Um, and we, we, uh, we eradicated everything and then it was like, okay,
we're out of here. And I looked around and went, Oh, wait a minute man.
I know we got the, I know we got the illegal marijuana out,
but what are we going to do about all this environmental damage?
And nobody was recommitting the damage or, or, or cleaning up any of this mess.
So I, the first thing I thought was we have a resource issue. That's crazy.
I mean, I've, you know, spent my whole career up to this point,
protecting wildlife, preserving waterways for all of us to enjoy, you know,
conservationist enthusiast, whatever side of the fence you're on. And uh,
nothing was getting done on that.
So kind of the light bulb went off a little bit that we need to do more to this
if we're going to get involved and we need to get involved in these types of
grow operations because it was a biggest environmental, uh, you know,
train wreck I'd ever seen.
And I'd worked a lot of traditional game worn stuff to,
to protect those resources. So once they
gotten everyone out and chopped all the plants up or did what they did,
did they try to reclaim the Creek?
Do they try to remove the dam and get the water to run back again?
At that time? No. No one was doing it right. And that's,
that's exactly rather what, what really, really kind of upset me. And again,
we were new at the game. We were the game wardens.
Nobody really thought of us as mainline law enforcement or you know,
narcotics task force guys or anything like that at the time.
So I wasn't gonna make waves. We just wanted to integrate and work together.
We wanted to unify these teams and what I really wanted to do at this point is
get back with my command staff, add, you know, my bosses and go, Hey,
we got a big, big problem out there man.
And there's more of this going on and we need to be involved even though it's
not traditional because we're sworn to protect our resources and we'll,
besides everything game wardens do that you think of from the wildlife
standpoint where mainline law enforcement, just like every police officer,
right?
We go through the same training and then what people don't realize is we through
two more months of
additional training in a really long Academy that's all wildlife specific,
wildlife forensics, wildlife ID, weapons identification,
all the things you really need to do the game or inside of it with wildlife,
you know, in the back country so to speak. Um,
but we needed to integrate with other agencies and kind of bring them into our
world if we were going to participate.
So that one case started the change in me to try to build those relationships
and get into tactics and tactical circles with some of these, you know,
SWAT and special operations units that would go in and do this job under normal
circumstances. If that was just being diverted by a rancher.
So if a rancher had done that and the Creek was dry, how would you,
how would you fix that?
We would've got with him and it's what's called a stream at alteration violation
and is 1602 and our fish and game code is the section, but,
and it's a very common section cause water's diverted for a lot of reasons and
you can divert water with a permit and certain circumstances,
but you can't completely denude a Creek that as wildlife thriving,
that's a waterway of the state for everybody to enjoy. Which this one was.
And if normally the case would be that they would have to re just have the,
the flow come back to exactly how it was before the dam and yep.
Yeah. That would be up to the rancher.
That would be up to the ranch or be part of a penalty. You know,
it could be a civil, it could be a criminal,
it could be a probationary fix it and you're okay. So there was no real,
there's no law involved or nothing in place rather to S when you found these
grow ops, like there was no previous precedent. Right, exactly. It was,
it was completely brand new. And this was, you know,
one of the first grows I think that any of us had found throughout the state of
California's game or in,
I mean there are other guys finding some things and working,
but being from the Silicon Valley and being inspired by those wild lands to
everything I became later and what I stand for, it was home, you know,
when it did hit home.
But seeing that and getting to meet certain guys from the Sheriff's department
in my first book goes into this whole learning experience of, you know,
ad hoc jumping in with other agencies and doing it. Is this the hidden war? Uh,
this was the first book more in the woods. War in the woods.
So we wrote war in the woods and then hidden war is the new one. Yeah,
hidden Wars, the brand new.
And that just came out and they're basically 10 years apart.
And the cool part about that, Joe, is when you look at the differences,
we do some major comparisons.
And what Warren woods covers is that chapter one's,
that first mission I'm telling you about right now because that was like being
live here. It is, you know, we're not in Kansas anymore. So it was crazy.
The people in the higher ups yeah.
That were in charge of trying to eradicate the grow up and take the cartel the
guys down what, so there, that was their job was just handling that.
It was just handling the, the marijuana aspect of it. Right, right.
And then the armed cartel guys.
So there was no one in place that was supposed to take care of the waterway.
There wasn't, that seems so crazy to me. It does.
It was one of those things that it was,
it was based on the fact that a conservation group,
like from an agency like fish and wildlife like us,
we just weren't involved where we would be looking at those environmental
damages. Right, right. But from a narcotics officer's standpoint,
you may see the damages, but it may not register. There might not be an,
you know, a mandate or even objective to clean that stuff up. And,
and back at the time,
DEA was funding all of our States and all of our County teams based on the
number of marijuana plants we eradicated.
So there wasn't any recognition of the environmental damages and any type of
funding based on how much reclamation and clean up you didn't know that would
change fortunately. And we were the,
we were a big part of making that change fortunately, but,
and there wasn't a lot of um, funding or, or you know,
point kickback or value to catch 'em bad guys to catch.
And some of these guys that were doing the damages,
so a lot of teams then were dropping it on helicopter lines,
cut and plants getting a big plant count, getting funded for it, taken,
taking the weed out. And that was it. So crazy. Like, yeah, I would imagine,
I mean, obviously I'm, I don't work in law enforcement,
but I would imagine there would be one person who would like detailed plan.
Right. And I would think that, well,
what happened while we found out that this Creek was dry? Yeah. Okay,
well we've got a resume. The Creek. Yeah.
Wouldn't that be like part of the plan? It would,
you would think it should be. Right. But it's all basically new territory.
Completely new. And so we're only talking about 15 years ago as well,
which is really crazy. Yeah, it was,
it was the start of a big shift in my career because I saw this as a big
problem. I also, up until in 2005 we were on, you know,
one of our first, second, third since third operations.
Since this one we just mentioned in 2004 and in August 5th of 2005,
the game completely changed cause that's when we were involved in our first
gunfight. And that's when my partner warden, who I trained in the Academy,
we were partners in the squad.
I had promoted to be the Lieutenant for two and a half counties,
the Silicon Valley, Santa Clara County, Monterrey part of, uh, um,
San Benito 20 days before this incident happened.
And I had young wardens that wanted to participate and do some of the stuff I
was doing with the other agencies on the marijuana, you know, operational front.
And this was, you know,
right above the tech capital of the world right there in Silicon Valley and Los
Gatos. We were in really steep, arid country, you know, August,
right before the age zone, dear opener, where you're all gearing up for that.
And was three game wardens, three Sheriff's officers.
I'm good Sheriff's officers that we've met on that first separation in 2004.
I just gave you the story on. And um, they were in harvest time,
they were fortified, they had heavy weapons like S K S is the AK 47 derivative,
sawed off shotguns.
And they had the growth set up where they were basically defending it.
And when we came in there was an ambush shot from one of the growers and that
was the one shot the bad guys got off.
And unfortunately that's the shot that hit my partner, um, through both legs.
And that bullet went through the right thigh and tumbled through his right leg,
then kept going through his left.
So he's down and we're trying to keep him from bleeding out of four holes for
the better part of three hours waiting for an air rescue. And we had, you know,
nobody in the country from the standpoint of a law enforcement team had ever
been attacked by these growers. We'd, you know, we chase them around,
they'd run away. Sometimes we'd find weapons. Oftentimes we wouldn't.
But so this was just a real eye opener.
Like what the fuck did we just walk into?
And plus my partner was real close to not making it.
And fortunately he did survivor.
I don't know that we'd be sitting here telling this story and talking about it,
but that day when I saw how well they were equipped,
the type of weaponry they had, um,
and the fact that I almost didn't come home that day, I went, okay,
this is super dangerous. We can't do this as standard patrol game or ins.
We can't do this doing just the traditional stuff.
We should stay involved in it. Because aside from being so violent,
the environmental damages Joe were the worst I'd still ever seen.
And they just kept getting worse and worse.
The more operations I'd worked in my home County. Right. Um,
so we learned a lot from that. There were a lot of tactical lessons there,
a lot of team lessons, a lot of things we could've done different.
And that kinda changed the game where we eventually got to what we're going to
talk about a little bit later now,
since 2004 have there been plans implemented to clean up Oh,
and also restore waterways and all the different absolutely. Yeah, absolutely.
And so now there's like a whole, they realize this is an issue and so there's,
there's precedent, there's very much so and,
and that largely came from what we saw, you know, in those early years.
The 2004 first stop on down there on Dexter Canyon Creek and then what we had on
Sierra Zola,
my partner was shot in 2005 about then we started also see the band poisons in
these grows like the carbo fear on bottles. Um, and just to give a background,
this stuff is so deadly. Um,
it was made as an insecticide or rodenticide just to kill anything that you put
on any type agricultural product.
And it was made originally back in I think like the 50s for legitimate
agriculture.
And then they found out how toxic it was and EPA banned it from U S or even
possession.
It's a felony to have it in the country and use it anywhere without special
licenses, um, through legitimate channels here in America.
And they ban it like 15 years ago cause it was so nasty.
But because it does keep everything off the marijuana plants,
I mean nothing can even get near it without dying almost instantly.
They still get it in third world countries.
They can get it in Mexico and it gets smuggled across the border with the grow
groups,
the drug trafficking groups because it's so effective regardless how poison it
is.
And we were starting to see more and more of that stuff as we were starting to
ramp more of a specialty to do in this job more, you know,
thoroughly and safely and get into the cleanup of this is one of the many
things.
I brought this up with Dan Crenshaw the other day and I talked about you and um,
cause he's a against federally making marijuana federally illegal.
And I said one of the problems with it being illegal is this,
and I was explaining these grow ops that for the rest of the country where
marijuana is illegal, the vast majority,
like what was the number that you said the percentage that was grown in
California that's illegally sold through the rest of the country? 70 80%.
So 70 80% of the entire marijuana population or marijuana product that you're
buying, if you live in, in place like South Dakota where wherever it's,
I don't even know it's legal in South Dakota where it's illegal. Right?
They're buying it from here. Exactly.
And it's because one of the reasons is because our state laws say that,
well first of all,
we're close to Mexico so the cartel members can come up really quickly. Right.
And then the other problem is that our state laws,
when we made marijuana legal recreationally here weeks,
severely lowered the penalty for an illegal grow up became a misdemeanor.
Correct. That was the, that was the thing, you know, when, when we started the,
the departments special team,
the spec ops marijuana enforcement team that had more goes into, um,
part of my job as being the cofounder of that and the team leader was outreach.
So I was speaking to legislative groups before we legalized under prop 64 and
then the tighter medicinal marijuana laws that came about that same time. Um,
and I was talking to anybody,
conservation groups that you and I would be part of. Um, preservation,
animal rights groups, high school kids assemblies, right. Watch out. You know,
if you're using weed, make sure you're not using this stuff cause it's so nasty.
Things like that. Um, and my whole point was if we're going to regulate guys,
we see a common, let's just regulate smart,
let's not lessen any penalties for the trespass grow that the cartels are doing
in our public lands and private lands and also the other gang groups.
And there's, there's other groups, you know, to a smaller extent. Um,
but unfortunately when we did regulate and all that was passed two years ago,
they did water it down so publicly and cultivation went to, like you said,
it's a felony to a misdemeanor.
And if you're at juvenile cultivator on public private land and one of these
juvenile, you know, cartel members and there's a lot of young ones learning,
it's an, it's an infraction.
And that took a lot of emphasis away from that part of the problem and left us
out there basically alone with a couple other agencies to fight it. Well,
for the average person that would sound before you knew about the cartel grows,
that would sound like a good idea. Well, Hey, if marijuana is legal,
what's the problem? What's the big deal? Exactly.
And then the other problem is these people that are buying this marijuana in the
rest of the country,
it's highly likely that they're going to have some of that pesticide on it.
Right. And how bad is that stuff?
Is that stuff ever killed someone from smoking this illegal marijuana?
We don't know if it's killed anybody directly because by the time it gets
distributed throughout the country, it does dissipate a little bit,
but it's still highly toxic. To put it in perspective, about three years ago,
we had two federal officers back East. Now even in California,
in a public land grow that had all that toxic on it.
So they have cartel grows out there. They do. They do. They actually,
we have them in about 2025 to 27 other States to a much lesser extent.
And something we need to look at is California. I mean,
we're one of only six Mediterranean climates on the whole globe.
So we are a great weed growing state, just like our wine industry, man.
We got great, great weather for it so we can grow outdoors and indoors.
I mean February to almost December. Right? And that's why it's grown here.
And that's why the black market, both in, you know,
the private land communities and the cartels are everywhere across the country
with this stuff. But they'll go wherever they can to, you know,
diversify the network. So we do have it in other States to a much lesser extent.
And then something we need to remember is,
even though about half the country has these, grows in him too,
to a lesser extent than California,
the same groups are under the same enterprise.
They're human doing human trafficking, doing gun running, you know, to fuel the,
the fight down in Mexico, uh, methamphetamine production.
And now the new synthetic fentanyl that's just killing thousands,
especially on the East coast, are coming from these groups.
So it's all one enterprise.
And of course we focus on the cannabis issue because that's what's affecting our
wild lands in our waterways. It's right at the hub. So yeah, it is.
It's nationwide. It's not a California problem. And we made really,
really careful, even though we're talking about a team in California,
game wardens,
we're trying to tell a nationwide story cause the nation needs to know,
well it seems like you, I mean not just seems like it is,
you guys were not trained for this and there was no one else there.
So it was like, Hey, put it on the game wardens,
they're going to have to handle this now. Which is really, to me,
kind of insane. It is. But then at the flip side, we're,
we're really passionate about protecting what you and I love, right?
Our Wildlands and our waterways and our wildlife especially.
So we have a passionate interest in protecting those resources and not to
mention keeping our public safe in the same,
in the same breath because these are in public areas. I mean,
we have a lot of these national parks. Um, we have like, you know,
not only you'd have the armed gunman that could, you know,
shoot at a Hunter or a hiker and a question,
anybody in the outdoors and enjoys our, you know,
what the great outdoors have to offer. Um, but you have, you know,
uh, all, all the other threats that come with that, you know,
it's not just an armed gunman. They're putting punji pits,
literally Vietnam era punji pits on some of these trails when upon Zipit for
people don't know. Absolutely.
So back in the Vietnam conflict with the via calling when do to detour our
American soldiers is they dig a pit underground on a trail and it'd be about 18
to 20 inches deep and you know, square to kind of cover a whole trail.
Then they cover it up with bamboo or leaf litter.
So it just looked like the trail and then our soldiers would kind of walk and
they'd step into that. And here's the sharpen sticks out of bamboo.
They're super sharp and they're pointed upward. So when you step into it,
you're going to share a shin, you're going to puncture, you know, your leg,
maybe an artery. And they would put human excrement, excuse me,
on the points to induce bacteria induced infection.
And basically you take our soldiers, you know, out of the operation.
What we started seeing in 2015 and the first one he found was actually in
national park up in Shasta County, a whiskey town. And uh,
it was a punji pit going into a gross site on a public trail.
I mean it was hundreds of yards, Joe from the Crow,
but anybody could have walked in on it.
We were running an operation with Shasta County and this was when we had our
full time dedicated team in the hidden warrior. Um,
and our point man was about to step into this thing and Arcanine Phoebe that I'm
sure you know,
we talked about it on Steven's show a little bit on mediator and also, uh,
Mike Ritland who has a show called Mike drop and he's a seal team,
three veteran and canine trainer. He really got into the dog stories, right?
We talked about that. But Phoebe, amazing dog,
she had been trained to sniff these banned poisons so she could smell it,
you know, a mile out with that. Amazing knows our canines have.
And right before our point man was about to step into it.
Phoebe alerted and Bryan pulled everybody back,
her handler and my teammate and sure enough he did some digging and pulled back
the tarp.
And then here's this punji pit and it had the band toxics actually on the
sticks. So what would that have done if one of us had stepped into it?
So that was a real aggressive anti-personnel technique that could, you know,
that could have decimated a Hunter or hiker or anybody else. So.
So that was wildlife or wildlife. Yeah, yeah.
Some of these pit traps for wildlife and these big, you know, Wells,
they're digging in cisterns and they're doing this to keep people out or they're
doing this for animals. Like what are the, what are they doing?
Something like that. It has to be targeted against people. But we have,
there's a lot of different things for animals too.
There's a lot of things to keep animals away from the plants. They'll do, um,
you know, they'll dig big pit traps that are,
they'll put garbage in them or they'll use them.
Like when we were in the middle of our really severe drought that we just came
out of here in California a couple of years ago.
All these mountains streams were just bone dry,
so they would go to the lower lands when we were doing a lot of work, you know,
in the Delta region, in the Sacramento Delta and the lowlands. And they,
even if they, you know,
were getting water from the Delta and the race land would dry up.
They would dig handbag Wells 2030 feet deep and they leave them open and they're
getting water from them pumping out water out of the bottom.
But those stay opens. So yeah,
our big and our big game animals drop into those or we could drop into them.
So multiple, multiple hazards. Yeah, exactly. What is the,
is there an estimate of how many cartel members are growing in this country
right now? If you say there's 27 28 States, is that what you said? Yeah.
What is the,
is there a rough estimate of how many cartel members are here right now doing
this kind of shop, this kind of stuff? You know, it's,
it's a real approximation because you only know based on who you catch or been
able to debrief. But like in California, we know from the amount of grows we,
we deal with every year just on the trespass, you know,
cartel front and the number of operatives it takes to run a grow and get it
started and then harvest it. I mean, conservative estimate, 10,000,
10,000, I'd say conservatives
and California just in California. And the reason we say that,
and I always go very conservative because it's such a kind of a silent
enterprise and it's really hard to get some of this data, but we've,
we've just validated it through the numbers of things we run across. You know,
when you look at the fact that it takes to skill growers that are vetted because
they cut their teeth down in Mexico, doing it effectively under the federal,
Alice knows and they grow well. And, uh, and,
and you mentioned this when you had Mike Baker on the show,
which was interesting, and you hit it on the head when you said, man,
these guys are really resourceful. You know,
you've got to respect their work ethic and, and you have to, because they're,
they're hiking waterline, they're hiking infrastructure in,
they're covering their tracks. Um, they're out there for six months at a time.
They were walking around with carpet strapped to their feats and they didn't
leave footprints. Yeah. And, and hitting more, especially,
we have a whole lot of photos in that book about things we've seen on trail
cameras and they will put felt lined, lined soft,
felt on their shoes, time up tight.
And if they're walking like an old forest road, you know,
this got a gravel base, you'll never see that track. I mean, you know,
you've tracked big game. I've done it. You know,
it's the same type of technique. And if you don't have any sign,
I mean they're really good at disguising. And we actually found a guy,
and I have a picture of this in the book and also in the PowerPoint when I,
when I teach to this throughout the country, um,
cow hooves actually carved out of wood because a couple of years ago we were,
you know, the us forest service,
a lot of this grow problem is on our national forests. You know,
Northern California in Northeastern California,
not so much Silicon Valley where I started, but the rest of the state,
even down here, and I'm,
what these guys would do is there's cattle leases on those properties where,
you know, ranchers can run cattle on part of the forest and you know,
or a joint on private property. And we were getting tips on a bunch of grows,
you know,
or you've seen him from the air or a Hunter or angler would report him or we'd
have a suspicion because of a waterway or we get see some plants from satellite
or whatever and we go try to find this girl.
And we weren't picking up tracks and we're, you know,
we were pretty good at finding these things.
Now we've been trial and error in it for a lot of lot of years. Um,
but we're seeing a lot of cattle tracks cause we're running around with cows.
And sure enough they were putting on cow hooves and strapping them on top or on
underneath their, their boots clomping around to disguise themselves as cattle.
Clever. Right.
And then once they get way up into a deep Canyon where they're going to put
their grow,
they just take them off and throw them in a backpack and then the light bulb
went off. Would we better look at, you know, our tracks a little more carefully.
So how do you guys try to go about finding these things? Do you,
do you rely on people reporting them or do you have like aerial surveys?
Like how do you, it's a mix of all of that. Um,
we get a lot of reports from people in the ground and our,
our best reporting parties are what we call our PS are hunters and anglers when
it comes to the outdoor public.
But anyone in the outdoors could run across some, but hunters and anglers,
especially because where do we go when we're,
when we're going to find a good water hole for elk or, you know, we're hunting
rock tail, we're going to go, you know, we're not gonna stay on the beaten path,
man. We're going to go down to the headwaters,
we're going to find a pristine area. We're going to get away from people.
So the people that are going the deepest into the back country. Absolutely.
Absolutely. And then they're finding the water, you know, source and they're,
maybe they're following it and it's dry or it's diverted.
Like what I found in 2004 that started this whole craziness. Um,
and then they run into a gro. We also, um, do find it from the air. You know,
we do all agencies. It's no, no secret, no, no tactical reveal. We've,
we fly to look for this stuff from the air.
I have a friend and found one on to hone ranch. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
A few years back. And, uh, I didn't think anything of it.
I thought it was just a,
some crazy person decided to try to grow pot and this is back before it was
recreationally legal. Okay. And um,
there was no shootout or anything crazy like that they do here.
They got there after. Yeah.
Either they realized that their grow up had been compromised and they took off,
but you know, to hone ranches enormous.
It's like 270,000 acres and uh, just the,
the gall of these guys to go deep into that ranch and set up this grow site.
Right. And the guys who worked there, they, I guess they just stumbled upon it.
I think they stumbled upon it because of garbage too, if I remember correctly.
Yeah. That, that, that follows track. And the thing,
now you're talking about a private hunting ranch.
It's got a catalyst and all that tones. Huge.
We'd done a lot of good stuff with toe and ranch and supported, you know,
good hunting programs there. But an interesting statistic,
when I retired last year in December in 2018, you know, I mean,
we keep stats ever since. One of the cool things about the,
our specialized team start in 2013 is we solidified all the documentation to be
spot on. You know, reporting was kind of haphazard throughout the state.
We weren't sure what other agencies were doing,
but we knew what we were doing now. And so I'm keeping that data.
And there was a real shift in just public land presence of these cartel growers.
And by the time I, uh, retired last year, I was almost a 50, 50 split.
So ranches like tone ranch, a private hunting club in the Silicon Valley,
one up in Shasta County. So you know,
where they're doing big time conservation projects to get black tail and mule
deer and Tulia elk and everything else up in numbers.
And now they've got this presence on their hunting club hitting one of their
sensitive waterways, you know, so, so it's,
it's not just a public land thing and it's really good for everybody listening
to know that you could find it anywhere and you stumbled on it. And, uh, it's,
it's funny you mentioned the reporting party's the cool thing after I did
Stephen's show on a, a mediator and talk to those guys. Um, we sort of get tips.
I actually got a tip and you know, and it's, it's in play.
I won't say too much more about it, but we'll definitely be,
we'll be talking when it's all over and done, but it's gonna get handled in a,
it's so cool to see the guys like you and I that hunt and love it and love the
passion of what's out there are out there stumbling on this stuff and getting
out safely and, and we're fired up enough not to wait. You know, we're,
we're calling people to say, Hey, it's out there.
Can you help us Ritz the warden sheriffs or are you ever guys getting incidents
of hikers or anyone getting shot at or, yeah, it's happened. It's happened.
Fortunately it doesn't happen a lot where we have a lot of fatalities.
But I want to say about five, six years ago, we had a, uh,
a father daughter combination on a deer hunt up in one of the DS owns in
Northeastern California and they were shot at by cartel growers going in on a
deer opener to try to harvest her first deer. You know,
she was coming up through the program. Yeah, it was horrible.
Unfortunately they weren't heard. They got out of the area, they reported it.
Um, we've had people run out of, you know, run out of gardens, um, by,
by some of these growers we have,
have other shots fired and we've had people just stay out of areas cause once
they see it or they see a guy holding a weapon like that in a marijuana
plantation, they know isn't legit. They're out of there.
So is there an area with a C?
I mean it's all public land mostly and private land. Ranch land, right.
But is there an area of the state where they, there's more of them, you know,
that's what I thought when I started. I mean, you hear about the humble,
you know, Trinity, the Emerald triangle, right, where just the hub of it.
And I thought it was more prevalent there and it's certainly massive up there.
Um, but I mean not from Silicon Valley where I'm from.
You wouldn't think of those foothills in that part of the state, you know,
being so overrun and during those, what I call, you know,
the formative years of learning this and getting involved in it and specializing
in it. And we were really,
I got to give a shout out to the Santa Clara County Sheriff's office and the
guys then that took us on as equals and my partners that really brought us in as
you know,
not only tacticians but tracking and able to identify sign as wardens do in
hunting thing in the woods where we could go and really specialize at this and,
and be a lot safer and do a lot better than when my partner got shot,
no five and we were doing 25 public and private land cartel grows in the Silicon
Valley at least 20 to 25 a season. Geez, that's a ton. That's insane.
And that doesn't seem,
I mean you only for folks who don't know what the season has explained that
yeah, the eradication season, what we call the, you know,
the grow season when we operate,
the heaviest is usually an early start would be some time may.
And then we'd go all the way to like about the end of September.
And I mean there's, you know,
there's some wiggle room on both ends of that depending on water and how long
the winter goes. But, but from may to pretty much the end of September.
So it's going on just somewhere in the neighborhood of five to six months.
And you're looking at 25 different operations. Yeah.
And that's in just Santa Clara County as an example. And we,
when we formed the full time team in 2013 and we had representatives and we have
representatives on our marijuana enforcement team, our fish, you know,
our agency specific team,
we would have guys covering every part of the state and responsible team members
spread out covering every County. And as of now, and we've been, well,
we had six full operational years before.
I retired now it's in good hands and the team's doing fantastic work.
We've had at least a grow,
if not several in every County in the state and most counties multiple.
So to put it in perspective, um, on an average,
your team have do 125 missions if not more.
So that's a 125 gross sites that we were responsible for doing the workup,
the planning, going in and doing the apprehension,
the stocking to catch these guys with our canines and with our tactics.
Then doing the eradication. And 90% of them are all, you know,
tainted in that Ferdinand and the carbo fear.
And sometimes to the point that it's so freshly applied that we can't touch the
plants for a couple of weeks. We can't even, even with protective gear,
with nitrile gloves, face protection masks, the whole nine long sleeves,
dangerous, that dangerous and no exaggeration. To put it in perspective,
the two officers on the federal level that were exposed just ingested some of
those fumes. And you get blindness, you get nausea, you can't breathe.
They were at a circulation, fortunately not fatally,
but they're at a circulation for weeks, sometimes months. And um,
federal OSHA came down with the forest service and of course working closely
from the state level,
we suddenly were under a lot of protocol on can decontamination what we couldn't
touch. And you know, new,
new basic tactics for our safety for human safety came down and it changed the
game. So these guys putting this stuff on there,
we may not be able to even touch the plants or even cut them safely or put them
in nets and contaminate all our gear until it has a chance to sit, uh,
dissipate a little bit. And that's 14 days.
So what would you guys do if you stumbled upon something and you knew that it
was freshly applied?
Would you just have a bunch of officers standby and guard the area to make sure
that these guys didn't come back to try to reclaim the plants is as best we
could because here's the problem with that. You know,
you get a big grow and you know, you can't go in and touch these things for,
you know, a couple of weeks maybe could be,
I mean it could have been applied that day.
It could've been applied four days ago. We hit it, we're not sure.
So we'll give it a 14 day window, we'll, we'll keep an eye on it.
But at the same time we're doing all these other missions and we're not getting
everything. And in how deep we're talking in.
I mean w we'd guys have to camp there sometimes. Yeah, sometimes.
So your guard can hike and yeah, we've, we've set on grows,
we've camped out overnight for several days.
We've surveilled drop points and you know, watched, you know,
these guys come and go and try to make sure they don't come back and you have
limited resources to begin with. Right.
So you guys are the initial jobs to protect wildlife and you're supposed to be
doing that.
So how much of an impact has that had on wildlife because you guys have been
diverted to these illegal grow ops. Exactly. Well, you know,
you hear the term, the thin green line, right?
And kind of what I'm all about being a game ward and now in phase two in
retirement,
I'm really trying to speak more nationally to what the Finn green line is and
it's never been thinner.
And through the thin green line basically just represents, you know,
game wardens and forest Rangers, border patrol,
but from the wildlife in the military of course.
But from a wildlife protector standpoint,
now that we have this cartel grow problem and you, you just hit it on the head,
brother,
look at the resources it takes and all that traditional stuff that we used to do
that we still do. Those problems aren't going away, right?
So we still have to check, you know, the night Hunter,
we still have deal commercial, wildlife sales and all
this, the ivory importation issue in the wildlife trafficking.
That's just blowing up.
So we're getting thinner and thinner and stretched further and further.
Game warden numbers aren't growing very much anywhere in the country yet.
The population and the impacts of people destroying wildlife,
especially on this cartel front,
just keep as acerbate ING, you guys are in charge of ivory
[inaudible] as well. We deal with all that. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. We have teams now,
um, in our agency and most of the States do call wildlife trafficking teams.
And it was a good program that came out of the Obama administration that all the
States had to do it. We were kind of already doing it,
but we had to formalize a little bit.
And that was an added challenge that happened right after we formed the whole
cannabis enforcement program, which started with, uh,
with the tactical unit that I, you know, co formed and ran.
And then all these watershed enforcement teams popped up for cannabis regulation
to check the new licensed growers,
people trying to do it legitimately in water use and make sure there weren't,
you know, abuses. Um, then wildlife trafficking became a huge issue, um,
the commercialization of wildlife as a huge billion dollar industry worldwide on
everything from abalone to sturgeon road. Uh, um,
black bear gallbladders and now ivory,
especially the black belt girl gallbladder was so weird and crazy.
Yeah. It's, it's just, it's like a Chinese medicine thing, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's an aphrodisiac. Yeah. But it's not, it's, no, it's not real.
But in Alberta, I think it's BC, now, BC, you know, uh,
black bear hunting's legal for food. You know, you can't open up the,
the stomach contents. Right.
They don't allow them to gut it because they don't want people to be
incentivized to sell gallbladder. Grab that goal. So strange.
So you can eat the bear. Yeah. But you can't even open up the cavity,
the body cavity.
So like the heart goes to waste all the other parts that people might eat. Yeah.
Yeah. Which, which we never like to see strange. It is. But again,
it gets back
to greed and profit and the market. Right.
When a gallbladder can be worth 40,000 or more,
well sees. Yeah. 40,000. That's how much,
that's how much a gallbladder can be worth for the black market. Right.
Is that freaking crazy? Doesn't do anything. That's crazy. It doesn't,
but because it believed that it does.
And it's one of those exotics that I got to have and I can't get Blackberry
rhino horn. Exactly right. Like [inaudible]. So we,
I did a lot of that type of work before I went into this, this met focus.
And it just shows you how many challenges game wardens have to do and it's not,
you know, the old traditional game or, and just out checking those
since there's anymore, I mean over text we're overwhelmed. Yeah.
That's no exaggeration. Now,
because this is now a problem that people are aware of.
There have been significant resources that have been allocated to try to handle
this stuff.
Like cause are there new programs to train these young officers coming up?
Is there like a specific task force that handles that and then the rest of the
guys handle fish and wildlife?
Or is it just same people but now you have a whole different level of
responsibility?
Yeah,
that it's really cool in California because we are one of the most progressive,
you know, game worn agencies. Um,
and it's interesting because I just spoke at the, uh, back in July,
I spoke at the new Ouija conference,
which is basically the annual game wardens conference for all of us from all
over the country. So get to work with all the States and you know,
Florida has so tactical unit for some stuff. Texas has it.
And we're the first state to have a dedicated, you know,
kind of tactical unit for this, this cartel growth threat because it's,
it's so big in California. Um,
but to share that with everybody nationally in my world, in the fingering line,
and for them to start having it happening on the refuges.
And even just to know this stuff's getting back to their parts of the world and
poisoning their, their cannabis users, you know,
unsuspectingly horrible information, right?
But we need to know it and a lot of guys didn't know it.
And so that was one thing to see, Hey, we need to have a baseline training.
And the way we do it here in California is we all go through a really stringent
Academy. Everyone gets their basic tools, arrest, control,
and defensive tactics.
She owned firearms training and all of that and get good at being the
traditional game warden and doing all the traditional stuff and they get,
you know, get their feet wet out, doing their own thing for a couple of years.
And then we start to find the people that have the motivation or want to get
onto a specialized unit like our met team or one of the watershed teams or the
wildlife trafficking team.
Very seldomly do we put a fresh person there because you know,
I think to really be a good game warden,
you got to cut your teeth on all the traditional stuff.
That's critical of just how I end up having to check guys with guns all the
time. You know, most cops look at that and go, that's crazy.
I mean everybody you check has a knife or a firearm. Yeah,
well fortunately 99% of them are guys like you and me that want to see a game
warden and game warn wants to see us.
But for that one felon that's on parole and he's in the woods hiding out.
And we run across that a lot. And I,
I ran across a ton of that down here and Soquel railing at the start of my
career and I've got some interesting stories about that. But,
so guys who are like the skip bail and then they go and hide and they've got
like a no bail warrant, their wanted on some warrant somewhere.
And so they're off fishing and they have an illegal firearm.
Maybe they're a felon in possession of a firearm they can't even have.
And now they're out in remote area where no cops gonna find me here.
And then I'm the new game warden in Riverside County, you know,
all fricking motivated, really green. I don't know totally what I'm doing yet.
Right.
And I'm in that truck cruising and something I got into down here that was just
crazy. But I will say this, it was a heck of a learning curve and I'm,
I'm really blessed to went out the way it did. And it was, I was safe in it,
but, um,
we would get gang bangers from LA here and they would go over into Riverside
County and get into my kind of rural, you know,
foothills and on the edge of the national forest and they'd have a K 40 sevens
and they'd have, you know,
automatic pistols and they would spotlight through these canyons,
gun and for everything. They kill rabbits and kill coyotes. They kill deer.
They get to the end of like a Canyon that has like a, an outlet of a damn,
throw a net out and spend all night there.
Just gillnet and fish and hunting freely and shooting and killing everything
with their spotlights. Grabbed their gilnet, grab hundreds of fish,
pack up and then head back, you know, back to the LA basin gang bangers.
I'm not kidding. And the craziest part. Gang bangers. Yeah, commercial.
Almost commercial fishing does. It does, it sounds nuts. Right, right.
And what would they do with the fish? Oh, they'd eat them.
Maybe they'd sell them, you know, who knows?
Usually with quantities that big they were getting sold.
But the thing that was crazy as I would be, you know, alone, I'd be in my truck.
I didn't have a canine yet, you know, and now I just, uh,
I just retired with like your Marshall. I have Apollo yellow lab, English lab.
She's amazing. Never going to bite a bad guy,
but she's gonna lick them to death and try to, to try to, you know, uh,
turn them away. Um,
but I didn't even have a companion dog at the time and I would go and run into
these guys and go, okay, this is what I learned in the Academy that you know,
that, that head on spotlighting stop,
that you never want to have her getting behind and blacked out and tracking him
down. Um, and next thing I know,
I got a case and I got all these freaking prohibited exotic weapons and I'm
going, this is crazy. I'm pulling these guys out alone.
I don't have a lot of baskets. It was just me. How many guys did you run into?
Sometimes it'd be two. One night I pulled like eight people out of a man.
Oh shit. And I was alone. Oh shit.
And they were all armed and it was one of my heaviest, most intense cases.
And I had been on one year,
so this was 1994 and what we were doing in the Riverside squad is we were just
saturating the area cause we were getting everybody from over on the LA side
here, spotlight and all our games. So we're like, okay, let's saturate this.
And back then Joe,
the game was to catch a spotlight or red handed cause there's so deliberate.
Explain spotlight. Oh yeah, yeah I should've, I should've done that.
But spotlighting is where you use a, an artificial light,
whether it's a handheld spotlight, a flashlight, whatever.
And you go into remote areas and you look to find animals at night because they
freeze, they're really relaxed,
their eyes glow and then you shoot them that way.
You kill him illegally at night after dark, which has never allowed, you know,
it's usually inner out of hunting season cause anyone's gonna spotlight a deer.
Nine times out of 10, they're,
they're not licensed or they're not gonna do it during season like we do. Um,
so they're doing that. So in the, in our world as game wardens,
that's the ultimate wildlife criminal because they're gonna kill dos, you know,
that, that have that unborn trophy buck for good genetics.
They're going to kill a trophy deer way in the raw, you know, that, you know,
needs to go another year or whatever. Um, so that's what we focused on.
That was like, if I can cut my teeth and get, you know, become a,
a reputable game or, and going after the hardcores, that was the game then.
So it was 94 and I'm pulling these guys out and calling him out on loudspeaker,
have got my weapon on him and I'm like, Oh man, there's a lot of guys out there.
I can't get them to jail. I'm calling back up. I got Riverside County coming in.
I mean we even have the, the,
the Sheriff's office helicopter come in several nights.
Once we got to know each other and they realized who is this game worn and what
are these game warns Riverside County going out into just crazy areas by
themselves.
They'd monitor our traffic and they'd come in on the helicopter and light it up
and call them, you know,
call these bad guys out on loudspeakers just to make sure we were okay and it
feels good when the Calvary comes on those nights. Man, let me tell ya.
So crazy sort of situations they just didn't know that you would ever run into
someone that's that arm that many guys in the van or what have you.
Eight people. Right. So they're,
the reason why you're patrolling by yourself was because they didn't anticipate
anything like this. Well and we didn't have the bodies, right.
This was one of the things that was crazy.
We get back to the thin green line concept and realize that one game warden is
responsible for 200 to 250 square miles.
Give or take. Whoa.
And you know how big Riverside County is on the inland empire,
hundred square miles, maybe more, you know,
depending on what part of this dangerous one game warden.
So a squad of seven game wardens to put in perspective, check this out brother.
So when I was supervising traditional patrol before we started the special ops
met team in Santa Clara County,
we always have vacancies because we always low on bodies.
We couldn't hire game warns fast enough.
We weren't funded for to where the case may be.
So we might have four or five game wardens for seven positions and we had to
cover all the Santa Clara County,
which is everything from the city to all those foothills.
And there's a lot of it in Silicon Valley.
People don't realize all of San Benito County, which is huge.
Hollister Gilroy, right where I'm from in Gilroy,
that whole area down to the South,
that is just massive mountain country full of wildlife. Um,
and then like part of Monterey County and I had five people in myself as a
Lieutenant. God is insane. I can't believe that.
So to go out on a spotlighting patrol to that point, um,
and have a partner with you, just one other game warden. That's tough. You know,
you're basically pulling a whole nother area you can't work night on or so is
spotlighting that common it,
it is still going on in the state and it's going on a lot. Um,
back then here,
because there had been so little presence here in Southern California,
it was off the hook. It was crazy.
One week in 1994 I remember I was a,
I had a really good ride along with me,
a wildlife biologist that just as savvy Hunter, great eyes.
He became kind of like my right hand man, Brian. Um, and we, I said,
we're gonna catch a spotlight or every night this week. He goes, you think so?
I go, what's that crazy, let's see if we can do it.
And so we went and worked all night long. We started on Monday night.
How do you catch them? Do you look for a spotlight?
Like would you get to a vantage point in glass? It's, yeah,
it's just like class in a big basin for elk, right?
You get in a really good Overwatch. So you get the most visibility, you know,
hide the truck and um,
you watch and you find areas where it's likely to happen and it takes a while to
learn where that's going to be just because you got this huge district and you
could have 20 places where guys spotlight.
But until you get into the areas of new warden and really get to figure it all
out, you don't know where to be. And it's a trial and error. But you know,
you took me six months give or take or just just going out there and scout hard
and, and I've seen where this road goes and how does that Canyon look?
What type of water do I have down there?
What am I seeing at low light in the evening when animals are coming to water?
Ooh, I got a whole herd of elk here. I've got a whole herd of deer.
I got some bucks, you know, I'm seeing other animals run around.
This is going to be a hotspot because guys can get to it.
And if you just put the time in, you just kind of lie and wait, you know,
kind of put your little hide together. Um, just like hunting a big game.
Eventually it starts happening.
And by 1994 and I've been in district a year down here,
I pretty much had my spots figured out.
My partners and other parts of Riverside did too.
So we'd all be out alone so we could cover more area and talking back and forth.
I mean, and I'm gonna date myself here, but cell phones are brand new,
so we all had those flip cell phones and we Holy you. Uh,
I'm going to be 51 in November. I'm 52 so we are about it. Yeah.
So we're right there, you know, all that era. So when I started,
I mean it was the flip phone. Yeah, let's start drawing,
communicate or call my partner Jerry. Love those. Where are you at?
They're great. And I'm like, where are you at? He goes,
I'm over here in Thomas mountain. Like I'm over here. You see anything yet?
I go, I got one light working our, I got to go and then I'll go home.
But that's crazy. Like you're talking about enormous pieces of land. Oh,
it's you guys responsible for, yeah. I mean for,
it's hard for people to put into perspective that don't spend any time in the
woods, right.
That you would be able to even find these folks in this enormous area. Yeah,
yeah. It's starts off as a needle in haystack type thing, you know?
But once you get into it, you get fairly good at it.
But it always is difficult because again,
just the percentages of catching a guy on the right night that he's going to be
out there.
And then you got the guys to kind of get savvy to known with game worn lives,
driving by his house,
looking for his patrol truck to see if he's out that night,
where's the truck parked? We start getting into that problem.
So we always kinda, you know, kind of maintain as covert as we can. You know,
we're known in the neighborhood and the thing is we live at home,
we work out of our homes, home office.
We're close to our community because if we kept our truck at a field office,
we have no response time all spread out. So we get very community oriented in,
in community functions, in conservation groups and everybody knows us,
whether it's a big city or a small little town in the mountains.
So you got guys doing the cat and mouse thing looking for us and you know,
making sure, Hey, is this truck there or is he out patrolling? Well,
maybe I won't go out tonight. Um, but, but that, that era Joe in, in 1994 was,
was off the hook. I, I didn't get a spotlight or every night that week,
but I got six out of seven and one night I had a double. So it was crazy. Wow.
And seasoned a ton of guns and you know, some guys were going to jail,
some weren't. Um,
but a lot of wildlife was say that night because they would've, they would've,
would've done a lot of harm. You know, most of these guys,
are they doing this recreationally for fun or they're doing it for food?
Like what are they, the, the group I was getting into down here, it was,
it was recreational. It might've been to sell the meat.
I couldn't prove that or it was just to go kill stuff. Um,
you do get people that need me, you know,
that do spotlight after dark because they need the meat and stuff like that.
And it's still a violation. We still deal with it as such.
But if we ascertain that we're going to be fair about it, you know, we said,
okay, look, you're poaching. I know you're starving. It's out of season.
It's in season. You have a tag, but you just really gotta get that meat. I mean,
there are certain cases where you just kind of feel for that person and go, Oh,
I see where the motivation was. You know,
and a very small percentage of poachers are that way, but some of them are just,
you know, they're just trying to feed their family and their,
it's a whole different game and we're going,
we're going to be fair about it or we should be fair.
But most of them gang bangers or most of them criminals. Like what is it?
Was there a down here, Ridge down here, 70, 80%. Yeah.
Had criminal histories, had illegal weapons associated with gangs.
So it was almost like recreation for that. It almost was what practice. Yeah.
Yeah. And I remember one case down here that was a pretty crazy one. It was,
it was three guys pretty inebriated, pretty liquored up. And um,
it was a head on stop and one of them had a, uh,
like a $50,000 no bail warrant for cocaine trafficking out of Mexico.
And that was in that week that we had, you know,
crazy spotlight and things going on.
So it was just the demographic of down here where up North that it wouldn't,
it wouldn't be necessarily a felon,
but that guy that just wanted that trophy buck and to get it cheat to get it,
you know, if I could give you a magic wand, okay. And you could like,
I could say, John, it's up to you fix all this. How do you do it?
You have unlimited resources, man. That's a great question. And all I'll do,
go into the bottle. The genie right here, one,
we put more game in the field because we do need more and we pay them better.
And here's the rub,
because there's this perception that game wardens just check fishing licenses or
they might not be real cops.
We're paid about 40% less than a County sheriff than a highway patrolman rather
than a city police guy. Right.
And because of you think it's because of perception,
a perception of public lack of knowledge perhaps.
Now that has started as far as funds get allocated, they say, well gee,
I can't Morton's right. This is the going rate. You know,
this is what we've always paid. You know, the raises are 80%. Yeah, yeah.
That's, we're in a car. We're in a constant constant salary equity fi. Um,
we've been, we've been, you know, really pushing that for, you know,
15 years plus or minus. Um,
something that really started to legitimize us. And um,
in 2010 when my first book came out, war in the woods,
that's when the wild justice game worn reality show.
National geographic channel aired for the first time and that was our agency and
that was the first of what are now a lot of game warden shows.
And the more the merrier because it's Christine, that one. Yeah. Yeah, it was,
it's good. Yeah, it was a, it was, it was us, you know,
so I'm partially mostly busting people for wildlife or is it gets to the
marijuana stuff too. Do you actually get in the marijuana stuff? Something,
the wild justice film crews really resonated with.
And a lot of the guys that are on the team now, myself included,
ended up being featured like their main people for the better part of like three
seasons because we weren't just bringing them the poaching cases,
the traditional stuff which needed to get shown even.
And we didn't have our formalized team yet,
but I was in bed with Santa Clara County.
Brian and canine Phoebe were up in Shasta,
but we were getting brought together for the show and he was starting to work
down with me in the Bay area and bring in that wonder dog Phoebe into the mix
that he had honed, you know, for years. Um,
and we started to show this cartel marijuana stuff through the show and
that's what got the ratings. That's what, you know,
that was worldwide broadcast and number one hit on Nat geo for three years.
And that opened the door. You know, we needed that exposure.
And it's the same thing with like writing these books and doing the TV I do.
It's a fine line between risk and some exposure or getting the message out.
And like I said, we're so thin on the thin green line.
We need all the exposure we can get. We're a little agency,
our funding's limited,
but we're doing a multitude of jobs even outside of the marijuana stuff.
So that started to help and now we're starting to get the recognition of the
professionalism and the capabilities we have,
especially with this tactical unit, um,
to hopefully help with things like salary and numbers.
And the magic wand brother is numbers, numbers,
numbers that are officers and they're paid well enough to live in the Silicon
Valley to live here in LA. That's hilarious. Right?
No one's paid well enough to live in. I mean, millions are moving out. Yeah.
And that's where,
that's where I grew up and if I wasn't embedded there is family member I
couldn't have afforded to stay. And I had great,
great wardens come in and do fantastic work that didn't want to leave Silicon
Valley, but they're like, I can't buy a house here.
I got to go to Butte County or I've got to go Shasta County, I gotta get my,
I gotta get in the woods a little bit, drive an hour to work, you know.
So if it,
has there been discussion like has anybody brought this out?
A Dan Crenshaw was not aware of this when I discussed it with him when there was
talking about federally legalizing marijuana that it's not just about saying
it's okay for kids, right?
It's about mitigating these problems that you have with cartels.
Cause when there is uh,
an illegal opportunity to sell something that there's a demand for,
then the criminals are going to sell it. Exactly. That's what you have now.
Exactly. And has there been discussion like to someone to bring this up?
Like this is one of the primary problems with having marijuana federally illegal
with California having it state legal that there is this massive confusion then
this, you know,
diminishing of penalties in California with growing illegally.
There totally is. And you know,
you've got the opposite ends of the spectrum and here's what we're learning with
regulation. And I've always said this, I said, look,
if we're going to regulate and we need to regulate to stop this black market,
let's do it smart. You know, let's for one, everything we,
we really tried to push here in California was regulate legitimate cannabis the
correct way. Keep people safe, test it, test it, make sure those pesticides,
the cartel pesticides are absolutely man in.
As long as people aren't hurting themselves or other people,
they're not destroying waterways. We're not getting in gunfights over it. Great.
You know, no problem. But for like the, you know,
the outdoor trespassing with these cartels,
let's take that funding and put more effort into stopping that, you know,
let's not water it down to misdemeanors and infractions and do things like that.
And, and you know, it's, and even we can even take cannabis out of the equation.
Joe from the standpoint of,
I remember a few years ago I was quoted by the associated press of saying if
cherry tomatoes were so desired on the black market and were illegal and people
were paying $4,000 a pound for cherry tomatoes,
we'd be having gun fights over cherry tomatoes and having banned poisons on
cherry tomatoes that are kids would be eating in their salads. You know,
because of the black market. So you can take, you know,
cannabis even out of the equation and look at the environmental impacts and look
at the public safety.
But we have to do something to regulate this thing uniformly over the bar,
across the board. And we have to break the black market. But what I've seen,
and I go into the last chapter of my new book,
hidden works sensibly on this is what are the challenges moving forward after
seeing regulation in play for two years, boots on the ground,
watching it and having a great relationship with legit will live legitimate
cannabis growers.
And I'll tell you a few stories that really opened my eyes and got us unified,
right? Cause the whole thing is we need to be unified on this, on this concept,
not polarize, left or right, anti cannabis, pro cannabis,
let's get unified environmental safety, public safety, all of it. Um,
but because of how we regulated and the licensing fees and the protocol and
everything else, we've had all of these, you know,
black market growers in the two 15 days that wanted to get legal and saw
everything coming in the cost to do it and being on big brother's radar or law
enforcement's radar. And they backed out. Like in Humboldt County,
we had it like,
I want to stay in the better part of 10 to 50,000 growers ready to regulate.
And we barely got a thousand, you know, and they went, you know,
I can't afford to go through this permitting process. I can't afford the delays,
so I'm just going to go back on the black market.
I'm not going to be on the radar. Wow.
And that has to stop if we're gonna regulate right now. Um, the thing that was,
was really interesting and, uh, I, I never saw this common, but when,
when we were about to roll out prop 64 and you know, it had been voted, uh,
for recreational and the medical laws were tightening up.
I was the first law enforcement guy being from a marijuana enforcement team to,
uh, to go into these a California grower association hosted grower meetings.
And my first one was in Santa Cruz, right over the Hill from my place. Right.
And I mean, I'm in the, you know, I'm in the BD use the cammo bottoms, the polo.
I'm going into my yard, my training attire for met,
and the look on 500 growers' faces when I walked in to that meeting, just like,
what's he doing here? Conflict of interest. He's working us,
he's a guy's watching our license plates. And I'm just like, guys,
everybody brief. I'm going to tell you a story.
I'm going to show you a PowerPoint. It's going to be graphic.
I'm not here to work anybody. You know, I'm here to unify.
Just hear what I have to say, no judgment.
And so I was all these guys aware of how big the situation was before you show
them. I would have thought so because they're in the industry,
they know we'd better than just about anybody. I would cry all the time.
They're not seeing the cartel.
It's just a little [inaudible] that I paid attention. They just grown pot. Yeah.
That's all. I didn't see that guy. Was that kind of true camera.
What's it got a backpack leg through the panels. A pipe. Yeah. But anyway,
I did explain that.
I mean these guys literally would VAK in hundreds and hundreds of yards of pipe
and have two being like for hoses on their back. Other tough. Yeah,
I've got, I've got photos in the new book on trail cam
with Phil on their feet covering their tracks with these seabags a a hundred
plus pounds and a spool of pipe going up, man.
Like don't know how hard that is to do. I mean these guys just took a legit job.
Yeah. They'd be like the best employees you'd ever had. They would. They would,
man. They're a, they're tough. And they're, I mean,
to look at the environment they live in for six months, man. Yeah,
they're all outdoors. But I was at this meeting and, uh,
I gave the presentation, I talked about it,
and it was crazy to see the look of shock on these, um,
these grower groups faces. I mean, some women were in tears. Um,
some of the guys were just like pissed off and pumping their fists and they're
like, that's bullshit. We are not about that.
We're not about doing anything bad with our water. We like our wildlife.
We just want to grow cannabis. We want to be regulated, you know,
and it was such a turnaround, you know,
from the traditional relationship between law enforcement and the cannabis
world. Um, and to see,
to be the one guy there with all of the growing community there and then go from
complete horror that I was there as an adversary or judgement or anything of
that or you know, to,
to do anything negative from an enforcement standpoint to suddenly have real
talks of what was going out. And, and I could kind of see the authenticity,
the genuineness on some of their faces, the way they reacted to my slides,
to the videos. And so, um, when I left that first meeting,
I remember I just got flooded and my patrol truck and I had Apollo with me,
my little lab, and she's an icebreaker. I thought, well,
it could be an interesting meeting. I should have the dog for pets, you know,
and she jumped in and I,
all these growers are coming to my truck and I'm packing up my stuff and one,
wow, this is weird. And it was all these, you know, farmer supervisors, um,
from all over the state, you know, Mendocino County up in the Emerald triangle,
Santa Cruz. And they're just giving me their cards and go, Hey Lieutenant,
I have workers, I have resources, we will hike in and clean up a grow with you,
let us help the met team, let us help the cannabis program,
whatever we can do and no charge. And, and that was genuine man.
I was really, really taken back by that in a positive way.
And I realized if we get the legitimate farmers on our side and they're aware of
this, they will help market that message. They have money and they have money.
Yeah. The legitimate farmers are making a lot of money.
That would be a great way for, you know, we, we, I mean tax wise,
I mean there's extremely high taxes on cannabis as it is. Right.
But if we could allocate that taxes absolutely to you guys. Yeah.
That would be incredible. Yeah. Where's the money going?
Let's have a certain percentage of it designated for wardens.
That's starting to happen too because what's now that we've had a couple of
years and we're seeing some of the regulatory funding and the tax trickle back.
Um, I'm in contact with my team all the time.
I still get to see him periodically and train and do things like that and really
give him a shout out for all the amazing, you know,
risks they're taken in the work they're doing and,
and promote their message with throughout their doing. But, um,
the money's starting to come back to us now. So we're starting to get equipment.
We're starting to get more bodies. We're starting to get like over time funding.
So the ridiculous long are small
team works. They're compensated for that just just happened literally, you know,
within a month or two of, of being on the show with you.
So we're seeing some positives from that. Those rates raised. We're trying.
Yeah, I mean we're trying alert the press. 40% is discussed this up.
This coffee's awesome. Bam. Good. We'll shout out Laird Hamilton, Hamilton man,
I'm not even a coffee drinker and I'm loving this. It's great stuff.
And convert now makes your mouth smack though. Gives you a little,
it does a little. Yeah, you gotta like clear your throat a lot.
Coconut oil and turmeric and all that jazz. I'm healthy.
Colorado was the first state to legalize it and Washington state did.
They have similar problems. They still have a black market, you know,
and the thing right now,
because we're not regulating federally and so every state,
anything that's grown stays in that state per LA. Right. But every,
all the demand is back East in these non-regulated States where they don't grow
it. So Colorado has a, you know,
an interstate black market that's done by the, you know,
quasi legitimate growers as well as the cartel element.
So there's still that black market thriving within, you know,
the black market cannabis industry that isn't cartel public lands. We've,
we've got different mixes and we'd be okay.
It's a different kind of a problem in Colorado.
So they don't have as many Carto grows. Not as many. They have some,
they have some, I've, I've,
I've talked to those guys and worked with them a little bit and they do have
some, but again, they're kinda like more, I'm at Montana now,
tight little growing window, you know, early winters, late thaws.
So they don't have a very big growing season outdoors.
The conditions aren't prime like they are here in Kelly. This is a,
this is a giant issue that is largely undiscussed and it's one of the reasons
why I was so fascinated by that podcast is that, and this is a one more,
one more piece of the puzzle when you're talking about border control, right?
That somehow or another, we've gotten into this,
this state and our country, this,
this place in our country where some people want to control the border and some
people don't want any borders, right?
And you have to understand that this is the number one problem with the border.
The number one problem with the borders, cartel violence, cartel violence,
cartel crime. That's the number one problem.
And the giant percentage of these people that are coming over and doing illegal
activity or doing it because it's profitable, right?
The reason why it's profitable is because it's illegal.
And so they can do these things and sell marijuana all over this country
illegally because it's illegal. And if it was legal,
we could regulate it. We could tax it,
the money could go into schools and pay for guys like you and,
and go to fixing this problem.
And instead we're playing this little stupid game where, you know,
some States are legal and some States aren't. And you know, let's, let's,
you know, and it's federally,
it's still a schedule one crime when there's millions of legitimate law abiding
tax paying citizens that enjoy it. And it's crazy. It is. And,
and to that point, you know, you, you look at, um, you know,
the discrepancy and just the inconsistency on cannabis regulations. Some States,
some not federally, not. Um, but when you get to the border issue,
you brought up that good point of it's not just that cartel element for this
camp,
this poison cannabis stuff or this toxically tainted cannabis is a better way to
phrase it. Um, it's the smuggling, you know, the human trafficking,
it's all those other crimes, that methamphetamine production. So I'm not, uh,
you know, I get asked a lot like, after, you know,
you had a great conversation with, uh, with, with Mike Baker on this was,
you know, our open borders going to work and no,
we've got to have some regulation.
It's just not gonna work because the world's not even,
so that's why open borders aren't gonna work. Right. If the world was even,
and there was, you know, I mean,
there's like extreme crime rates at costs and you know,
I had ed called her on, on who works for Mexico.
We just started dialogue and last week I liked that guy. Good guy. Yeah.
Boy does he scared the shit out of you though?
When he tells me the stories about Mexico, about how bad it is down there. Yeah.
And uh, there's,
there's just an insane amount of violence that's going on down there and an
insane amount of crime.
And so much of it is connected to the illegal drug trade. Yeah.
And look, you're not going to kill it all if you make marijuana illegal,
but you would kill a percentage. At least it would make it a little bit better.
And you would stop that. Yeah. And one of the things we do, we get from,
from getting that regulation, if we can stop that black market for,
you know, cartel weed, we're gonna save a lot of wildlife. Yes.
We're going to preserve a lot of waterways, right.
Because all those other crimes are very heinous and very destructive.
And I hate to see the human trafficking and all the math problems and anything
that relates to violence or a deterioration of a soul. But you know,
I love the wild man. Woods are matured. Yours too. I mean,
what you do for conservation,
the elk hunting that you're doing and all those different things. I mean,
it's just, it's magical out there and it's just,
most people just don't even know, I don't think. No, but I mean,
don't get a chance to experience what it's like to actually be real woods in the
real woods, which are,
which are getting shrinker smaller and smaller and smaller, even here in Cali,
that has so much beauty. Um, but I look at it this way, I said, look,
if we lose all of our open space to a problem like this,
and it compounds the problem and we lose our wildlife and good water,
you may not be into the outdoors right now. You might be a preservationist.
You might be, you know,
on your fricking digital device all the time and looking at wildlife through a,
through a screen.
But if you ever do go out and you get that peace and tranquility and you get
centered, like we do run a trail hiker, you know, LA County, mountain trail,
open space, don't even get that far in the woods. It's just soothing, you know,
brings us back to our center. And you know,
if the new generations that aren't getting that from the cities can get that or
they can get their kids doing it or their grandkids are here about it,
but it's not there to go to, um, that to me, man, we're just,
we're just not paying forward enough. So this is,
this is something I got to stay on and I really appreciate you and what you
stand for. Um, because of the message. I think just so many people don't know.
Yeah. I just think that's a big new is they don't know.
What's interesting to me too is that the allocation of resources that it's,
it's so when you have something that's illegal,
you're not getting any of that money. No. And if it was legal,
there's an enormous amount of money that could go to schools and fix the roads
and we can allocate it to a bunch of different big time,
really positive ways to spend it. Yeah. And we're not doing that.
And it's,
it's the reason why is because it's illegal and this is crime problem is very
similar to what they faced during prohibition with alcohol and [inaudible] the
rise of organized crime. I mean, right.
That's where they were getting their money from because there was such a demand.
It's really a disgusting,
dumb way to approach a problem that is in many people's ideas of social problem.
That money could go to so many different positive things. Yeah.
And when we're perpetuating it through that reason and many others,
we're basically, you know, we're basically embedding the problem in our country.
And ed said this called her own,
we were dialoguing earlier this week and he said, you know, um,
he's kinda looked at things from the border and South and the issues coming in
from the border, from the cartel front. He said, you know,
now I'm getting wind of your book and I'm starting to analyze what you're,
you guys are fighting on the ground inside the borders in California,
in the rest of the country. He goes, it's embedded now. I mean,
it's not like it's just coming across.
I mean the enterprise is embedded here in the nation because they have the
pipeline, they have the distribution,
they have a market and they don't have to deal with the border issue.
And they're comfortable because of exactly where we're at and what people are
aware of. So in California that it's just a misdemeanor,
which is even more insane. That's got to change. It's got to change.
And I don't mean it should be something horrendous if you're,
if you actually have a background in crime,
especially particularly violent crime when you get caught doing something like
that. I mean it should be severe, severe penalty.
It should absolutely be severe.
Now that the saving grace of that is when we get the environmental crimes that
we bring from the fish and wildlife standpoint to those charges for these guys,
we get it back to felony status because we had an interesting thing happen. Um,
as soon as all that regulation started two years ago and the wa, you know,
those trespass grow cramps were watered down to what we're talking about.
District attorneys all throughout the state said, Oh man,
we're not going to be able to prosecute these crimes. I mean,
we're not gonna have a, you know,
we're not gonna have a jury that's sympathetic to these issues. Um,
it's not worth it. Some Sheriff's departments were saying, Hey,
we know how violent these guys are.
We know your team's been in like six gunfights man,
your partner was almost killed in Oh five in the first one.
You guys take these guys head on, you know, you want to protect your wildlife,
whatever,
but they're not stopping and it's a misdemeanor and we can't convict them so
we're not going to play. So the backlash of those crimes being watered down,
Joe was team stopped working at except us and like the feds, you know,
and not only that DA's couldn't prosecute. So, um,
I remember speaking for the California district attorney association on this and
say, and there's a solution. Everybody,
no matter where they sit on the cannabis spectrum,
everybody hates to see Bambi dead, water poisoned.
Everyone has a little bit of environmental passion.
And I'm on both sides of the fence. And that's where I say, here,
we get to the [inaudible],
we can unify and not worry about where we sit on the periphery or against. Um,
and if you take these water code enhancements,
if you take the felony and the penal code from the band, toxics like Carbofuran,
um, if you take a stream bed alteration,
diversion or dead wildlife are littering close to a state waterway,
you stack all those up, you get all these penalties and you can convict on that.
You know, even in a sympathetic jury on see a cannabis issue.
So we started to prosecute these cases and it started to come back and it's an
arduous end around, it's more work than we should have to do. But,
but we're doing it now when they find these cartel members and they bust them
and they do prosecute them for these, um, felonies, what happens?
Do they, they don't get deported, right?
They stay in this country and they go to jail here. It depends. Um, they,
they'll go to jail here.
If it's a sanctuary type state scenario and they're gonna, you know,
stay in our justice system and they will do jail time here. Um,
if we're working with ice in feds and Homeland security,
especially ice agents and they are classified as deportable felon,
they will get deported. They'll get on a watch list.
Did they get deported to jail or did they just get freed? Well they,
they're supposed to go back and be in custody over on that side.
Does that always happen? Air quotes supposed to, supposed to operative word,
supposed to slip.
If there's someone who's high up in the cartel or is making a good amount of
money for the cartel, right.
It's highly likely that with a lot of corruption they might go free. Very,
very true. And the case has happened where we've, you know,
got some of these cartel growers deported and a week later they're in a
different growing kit in Northern California.
We've had some situations where we've,
we've seen the same guy for 20 times wax,
no joke.
So you've busted them how many times we did or another team did or sort of
service does. Did 20 times. Yeah, they'd been, they'd been,
and they're still here and they're still here. Holy shit.
Because of what you just broken system as the jacked. Right.
And what you just said,
it's like cause of the cause of the money involved and we know and I go into
this and hidden wore a little bit what I can talk about under,
you know just what we learned without putting names out there is it's four to
$7,000 for these grow organizations in these cartel cells to bring their best
growers back across and it's a drop in the bucket and they don't even consider
the border a border.
They consider it like a speed bump on the four Oh five freeway.
So how do they get guys in? Do they use boats? Do they use tunnels? All of it.
All of it.
I was always thinking like how the fuck are you going to protect the border when
you just get a boat and discount like well pass in Poland somewhere in
California and hop out. Yeah, we'll something,
something we learned recently and it's been about the last five years and it was
really starting to hit the California coastline in the Oregon coastline heavy
when we started our unit in 2013 was these panga boats and you know,
they start where panga it's called panga, P
a N G a called a panga boat. And they're, they're uh, you know, the,
the inside the mazal on peninsula and they're loaded up with 6,000 pounds of
tainted weed but grown in Mexico,
same stuff they're doing here with the same toxics or meth or people or both in
a couple of growers or you know, transporters and they'll run this boat.
It's a one way boat and it's, there's a lot of money in it. You know,
there's big four stroke motors. It's painted kind of the color of the ocean,
so it's hard to pick up from. The air goes kind of fast.
It's made to carry big loads and they'll take that thing around the peninsula.
They'll fuel up off shore somewhere off the San Diego coastline,
maybe a hundred miles out and he's got one up there. It is nice Jamie.
Well that's a lot of weed. That's a lot. Yeah.
I got some pretty cool pictures in the book.
So these guys just pulled the boat in and then this is obviously one that got
busted and then they just have someone waiting for them.
An example of that stuff in the trucks and they've got a distribution network,
a ready to go, and then that boat's just disposed of. And again,
ladies and gentlemen,
this is all because of an illegal demand because it's illegal.
This stuff wouldn't be profitable if we are growing in here in the United
States.
And if the only way you would sell it at a store was if it was regulated and
licensed and you knew that it was tested and it was all grown here.
He had a certificate of where the farmer was that element out of it. Yeah.
So you take that element completely out of it and they would let you know.
Obviously they're still selling fentanyl and all sorts of other shit that we
don't want legal. Yeah, but it's so dark.
It's such a confusing, confused.
It was this bang of boat found with $18 million worth of weed.
That is a lot of weeds. Weed is not expensive.
How has a boat got $18 million worth of weed? That's a heavy load.
That's a typical load to Joe and a,
that was probably one of the Monterey boats we helped on cause we,
we interdicted a lot there. But um, yeah,
it's a daunting task when you look at that dude on the right.
I said just shoot him in his face. Guy looks super dainty. Angry.
Yeah. Very mad. Very angry. Not try it up here. Yeah.
I mean obviously I'm not, I'm kidding about shoot him. But yes, their,
their situation is just as great. I mean you live in,
in Mexico and you're fucked and there's no way for you to get by legally.
And you're a young man,
you get recruited into one of these cartels and next thing you know,
you've been in for 10 years and you committed a few murderers and you're
involved in drug trafficking and you're down the slower. Yeah.
You're down that slope. It's done. How do you get out of that? You really don't.
And there's no, there's no avenues for them. There's no established, you know,
community outreach centers like Hey cartel members,
like why don't you just grow cherry tomatoes instead? Right. Or you know,
there's no positive reinforcement and people that give a shit, you know,
it's horrible. Yeah. I mean,
and a lot of that again is backed by illegal drug sales.
If you don't have illegal drug sales,
you don't have nearly as much profit or incentive and you have less of that.
Yeah.
It sounds counterintuitive for people to make things illegal that are legal,
are make things legal that are illegal and you would, you would stop the crime.
But that is really how it
works. It is. And I always look at it this way, I said, look it,
regardless of where you sit on the emotional spectrum on this,
against cannabis for cannabis,
let's all look at the issue of environmental purity,
safety in America, and really be realists of what's going to help the problem.
And you hit it on the head when you said, well, yeah,
there's all that mess stuff going on and this, that and there is,
but I'm a realist and we got to do something right now.
And I think if we're going to federally,
federally regulate to any type of consistency,
we're still many years off from that, you know,
so what are we going to do in the meantime if that's going to happen?
We still gotta deal with this, this mess going on in pride,
predominantly California and all this stuff.
Getting out to our public and being tainted. Um,
we still have to deal with the meth issue and the gun running and all of that.
And, and knowing that it's embedded in our country,
we need to have people aware of it and with not only law enforcement, but bring,
bring that thin green line a little bigger with conservationists like yourself
and people that are in the know, people that are in the outdoors. Um,
and just putting the word out. I mean it's,
it's crazy that 10 years have passed since the first book in 10 years have
passed since we did those, you know, those three good years of while justice TV.
But in that interim, it's been a specialty of ours. We built a team that's,
you know, notice now for being pretty, you know, pretty uh,
innovative and progressive and non traditional,
but putting up some pretty good numbers when it comes to the environmental
damage and the public safety issue and how much we took out and bad guys we
caught and what our, what our kit with canines did, especially canine Phoebe.
Um, but we're, we're only dropping the bucket. Yeah.
It's one team out of part of the state and other teams are doing some stuff too
at the federal level and state level.
And we're only getting maybe 50% of this stuff if we're lucky.
Is it really that much? It's at 2% is high. That's, that's optimistic. Yeah.
That's against the magic wand. Yup. If I gave you the magic wand, John,
do whatever you want, how would you, how much,
how many more officers would you hire? How big would you make the task force?
How much would you branch out your operation? I'd make the tactical unit,
the met team,
have the tacticians going just after the cartel front that we formed. I'd,
you know, triple or quadruple it, you know,
have a team like maybe four teams in the state, you know,
have them all trained together,
have them all uniformly committed to tactics and training. Because it is,
it is quite advanced with some of our guys of doing from a sniper team to
tracking to, you know, all the stuff we get into. Um,
not only for this job but for anything else we come up with right from, uh,
from, uh,
from an American public safety threat after nine 11 stuff changed and we hadn't
gotten into this grow mess yet. Joe, you know, with, uh,
to the level of the cartel front. But I knew back then, you know,
game wardens are gonna have to be tactically trained as well as any other law
enforcement officer.
And we're going to have to have our own tactical unit cause we're doing some
pretty crazy stuff for wildlife crimes, you know.
And then Homeland security on a potential terrorist threat.
You need to have tactical units that are there with every other agency and
military teams because we're all thin in numbers.
And if something big goes down,
I need to know that the sniper team we built with Mitt and these tacticians
can go in and integrate with San Jose PD SWAT.
They can integrate with military personnel, you know, wherever,
same type of deal. And we've used,
we've gone the same direction with some of that good training and found the
right people to do that just under a game warden umbrella because it's gotten
that crazy. So it is crazy that you guys were required to do that.
I mean it's sort of like asking a teacher to also be a Kickbox or something.
The idea that you guys were supposed to be doing one thing,
which is the a game warden and then all of a sudden you're involved in narcotics
trafficking and cartel operations and getting shot at and you bring in dogs and
yeah, these dogs that you're training, you know, Phoebe was,
I there was very interesting listening to how effective and using Belgium Malmo
was that we using primarily our main dogs have Belgian Mel and you are powerful
dogs. They are amazing. So smart. Yes. Look in their eyes you can see it.
Right? And like, Hey man, how are you doing?
They're not like looking at a poodle. No, they're not like looking at our labs,
not Marshall Apollo. You looking at me with that sweet little phase. No,
those times out. Yeah. The thing that's cool about these dogs and um,
and I can't talk enough about it man. Cause no matter where you sit,
everybody loves a good dog story. And you know, some people say, well,
dual purpose, you got to bite guys. What's with with that is, you know,
really aggressive and um, when you look at, it's a lifesaver for everybody.
It's a lifesaver for us. It's a lifesaver for the suspect to for,
because it usually involves a potential gunfight that the dog basically,
you know, alleviated because she or he was there. Um,
so we got our canine program in agency going kind of full speed around 2008 ish.
And we have three, we have three levels of canine.
We have like the companion right along canine that kinda does everything with
ya. She's never going to bite anybody. And that's Apollo. That's like my lab.
Right. And then we have the detection level dog.
And most of those are Labradors. Like Marshall, like Apollo,
because labs have such amazing noses, they really can hold on sent, you know,
they,
they can train to D to tech mini sense and we certify them in different things.
And then there's the Phoebe's, you know, the Belgian males or the shepherds.
And really it's become mostly males now in our agency and Y mows or shoppers.
Um, they just do better in the heat. You know,
the shepherds are longer haired and we're in a hundred degree weather.
We're on long hikes, you know,
we're unsupported in those dogs might have to sit quietly after hiking eight
miles and sit in a prone quietly while we're watching and observing and stocking
it on suspects to make an apprehension and arrest safely and hopefully avoid a
gunfight. So, and we've also found with the, with the males that like I said,
they just hold up better on average and there's certainly exceptions to that.
Um, but when we got our dual purpose program back on track,
these are dogs that will bite when they need to on command,
but they have great noses. Solas still detect wonderfully, you know,
finding evidence, finding tainted weed, whatever the case may be,
a firearm of a bear, gallbladder, all of that. But they'll also, you know,
like Phoebe was
nicknamed the from missile because when it was time for her to go to work and
some guy was going to pull a weapon on us, she was all business.
And a cool thing about a dog like her and [inaudible] and Mike [inaudible] and I
got into this on his show, especially in, he was blown away. He said,
I've never heard of a dog in a domestic law enforcement team that's had like,
she had 116 apprehension bites in her career and she had hundred and 16 no joke
jokes. She has 116 cartel guys out there telling stories about this dog.
They're saying no more para. I've been bit too many times. No.
But the cool thing about that was a standpoint of life she saved and she also
arrest another eight to 900 that she didn't have to bite in her career.
That's a lot. How many of you guys arrested?
When I retired we were over a thousand. Wow. In five and a half years. Yeah.
And we and against all these, the all grow ups, all grow ups. Yeah.
These are all grow ups are related to grow up.
So that then these are all guys that are armed.
All guys that have knives or guns, you know,
you're not getting bit unless you know you're a deadly force threat on some
level or a significant threat. So, uh, yeah, it's been a lot of guys.
So that number that you're talking about, 10,000, that really is conservative.
Very, I think very much so. Yeah.
That is so insane because if you fly over like Humboldt or any,
any of these areas,
I can particularly met Asino Northern California that the density of the forest
and the, the, the public land out there. Yeah, there's a lot of land.
There's a lot of land and a lot of opera, you know, potential we're not seeing.
So, and that's still still thriving. So when you, um, you know, when you,
when you look at Phoebe as a canine and you go, well, let's see,
she was in the field doing these type operations for about seven or eight years.
And yeah,
that's great from a record standpoint in numbers and the life she saved.
But it gives you a, like a, like a snapshot of the issue.
How many guys did we not catch that were out their arms in a way that we weren't
involved in? You know, we weren't involved. So, um,
and the dogs have just saved lives, man, they have saved Phoebe.
I go into this and the new book,
especially in 2012 but right before our team started, Phoebe saved my life.
Brian's life and all these other operators in Santa Clara County in Silicon
Valley,
right where I grew up because she engaged a guy that was pulling a Russian
automatic pistol on me and I was the support for the, for Brian.
I was basically as canine handler or support guy and Brian had to deal with this
other growers,
partner that had a big Tarus judge revolver on his hip and he was pulling it.
So he goes for that guy and says, John,
just take my dog and Phoebe's long bite and he's biting this guy in the calf and
you know this guy's nose down and we don't know he's got this weapon.
And I start to see it coming out and I get on him and I do what I need to do
with some physical control and some strikes and whatnot to get the gun out of
his hand.
But had she not been on that guy on a bike show that guns turned on me at five
feet. I'm engaged all the Rathman behind me. I'm, you know,
I'm in a gunfight again. We've been in too many of those already.
How many gun fights you've been in?
Our team's been in six [inaudible] and I've been on the ground for four out of
the six that our guys have been involved in and they've all been around this
particular problem. Um,
we had a lot less once the team got formalized and so we started using dogs,
but we still had to during the window of the team being operational that we
couldn't avoid. And dogs played a big part in that as I go into the new stories,
so crate, I mean,
when I was listening to that podcast with Steve or now the media podcast with
you, and I was like,
I can't believe that there's not some sort of another division of law
enforcement that gets involved in this and that we were requiring game wardens
to essentially become something completely different. Yeah, well,
well we still have other law enforcement agencies involved.
Forest service dedicates a lot of people to it because a lot of this is on
federal lands. So we worked hand in hand.
Some Sheriff's departments still work at um, BLM works at,
but very few agencies have a dedicated team within their unit just for this
problem. And it was a big step for us. And,
and even though it's not a traditional thing like we,
like we kind of talked about when we started, um,
all of us that are doing it want to do it. I mean we really, everything we do,
like I said is important.
We'll never negate anything [inaudible] a wildlife officer game warn has to do.
But for us that see this problem is the most severe,
which we all acknowledge and you know,
we're those kind of team members that have the military, the law enforcement,
tactical experience. We're just wired for this type of stuff. And we know,
I feel like, you know,
in 28 years of being a game warden it felt like a 10 year career.
And even though we are, we are certainly underpay. Like I mentioned,
I had a dream job, you know it was really awesome to, you know,
cause you're really doing a difference. I think we're making a difference.
Exactly.
I think every case we make matters and even though it's an uphill battle and
with the whole regulation debate and stuff,
every grow site we interdict and stop and take that, you know,
tainted cannabis out of the market or restore that waterway and clean up that
gross site and we cleaned them all up now that we go into and the other agencies
now support us and clean up with their own resources because game wardens have
got so legitimate in working with other agencies that are non conservation
groups, Sheriff's departments, right.
A DEA task force type units and they're like, okay, we agree, we see,
we see the value in reclamation and clean up.
These grows to the point where Obama's drugs are addressed.
A lot of us when my team was starting up and our group was working heavy and it
was a real compliment. But it finally, more importantly,
it got the news out where he said,
I want this model rewarded what fish and wildlife is doing with this cleanup.
I mean, you guys are arresting guys. That's great. You're taking guns away.
Your key, you know,
obviously somebody is going to be saved because these guys are violent,
deadly and you're radicating the plants. It's fantastic.
Keep it out of the market. They're poisoned.
But unless you're doing that reclamation component,
I know it's dirty and arduous and tiring and it takes resources. Um,
you know, we're not doing, we're not making the biggest dent.
So then funding started to reflect from the federal level through da funding
rewards for reclamation. And that was like one of these men. It took,
it literally took 30 12, 13 years to get there.
So when you guys have a situation like the first one that you found in 2004 and
you stumble upon this dry Creek and there's all this debris and as toxic
chemicals,
like what kind of a cleanup is involved here and how long does something like
that take before you can bring that Creek back to where those steel head can run
and to the way it's supposed to be.
We're looking on an average one full day and we're looking at having to have a
helicopter for a whole day and having to have anywhere between, you know,
ideally 12 to maybe more officers in there.
And a lot of it will have some volunteer groups coming in.
We have a program in California, fish and wildlife called the interview program,
the nature, the natural resource volunteer program.
And when we started our pilot program in 2013 we did an operation called
pristine to test this theory.
If we could have this full time team being effective.
And if it wasn't for like 40 of these volunteers that are helicopter trained to
go in with us and do a cleanup, we would have re-acclimated you know,
less than half of what we were able to do. But when we do a reclamation,
it's probably more expensive than doing the tactical operation planning and the
take down for the first part of the phase because you know,
helicopters are thousands of dollars an hour in blade time and you're bagging up
trash, you're getting dirty. Um,
some of these water lines like you saw in the spools and I told Steven on his
show and Mike on his show as well, um, with mediator and Mike Trump that,
you know, we tracked a waterline almost three miles once that was a lot of,
and pipe. It went,
I mean water sources and Merseyside County on the Pacheco pass highway in my old
home district. And it went all the way down.
Pacheco pass onto this private ranch where the growth started. And it was,
I think it was like 2.85 miles handmade, hand laid and buried under like,
you know, forest roads or fire roads you'd see on like a, like a tone ranch.
Yeah. 18 inches underground buried across the road.
So we'd been embedded ditch for three miles.
That's a lot of work and it's a lot of work. Those guys are fucking up.
They should do a real job. They would make a lot of money, change it, fix it,
do something different. Yeah. All right. But the, the,
the point of it was we have to, we have to pick up all that pipe. Yes. You know,
so how long is it going to take? You know, two of my guys and miles of pipe,
18 inches of ground. That was a couple days. You know, on an average one,
we're going to go a quarter to half a mile at least. And you know,
even though that black pipe isn't poisoning the water directly,
once all the poisons are taken out, that waterline is an infrastructure piece,
that it's there, black gold. I,
I kind of use the term black gold when I start teaching to this,
that if you leave that water diversion in place and you take out their whole
gross site, you know, you take out their camp and all that,
but all they gotta do is reconnect a waterline and put a 10 up and bring in
seeds and get their little camouflage system going.
Very small investment to put a grow back there.
And one of the things that really got other agencies convinced that we need to
replicate to the way we sold it is not only on an environmental protection
standpoint because other agencies care about the environment,
but it's not a mandate that for not funded for it, but it would,
it was something like, um,
it's also deterrence because when we debriefed some of guys,
we caught these upper levels and I dive into this in the new book especially,
I finally got to ask the questions, um, to these upper level, you know,
cartel guys run and grows, run in math, run it all. And I said, you know,
it's interesting. Um, we notice that when you got,
when we eradicated gross site,
traditionally back before we change this process and we just take out the plants
and we leave, we noticed there's a grill,
like they're back there next year or maybe two seasons again and it's the same
group. And the answer I got was, well,
we know how taxed you guys are and how much resources you expand and you can't
possibly get all of our grows. So we'll try it, you know, in 50% of the time,
even though it was rated like two years before and it's on your radar,
we'll actually get away with a harvest. And I asked, well,
if we start doing this reclamation and we take all your stuff out and restore
the waterway and move the tents and just completely sanitize the site,
let all the natural growth come back, preserve the Creek, he said,
we're not going to come back to that too much effort.
We're going to bring tens of thousands of dollars in new infrastructure.
We're gonna have to run a whole nother water line. Um,
it's already on your radar, you know,
from a couple of years ago when you guys rated it.
That's not a good business investment in a business model for us to take that
chance. And we kind of knew that because we were seeing the trend on the ground,
but to hear it from this guy's mouth and validate what we suspected and have it
come back as true and all the other things I got to learn. I mean just,
it changed the game for us. And that happened,
I'm going to say about a year to a year and a half right before we started our
unit. So we went in building the met team in 2013 with this mindset in place.
And uh, um, Nate Arnold who was a district, um, a captain at the time,
my partner in, in building this,
and I'm going to give a shout out right now to Mike Kerry on who is our chief of
the,
the law enforcement division and one of my mentors and friends way back in the
Academy in 92.
He green-lit us to test this program and take all of us out of patrol in an
already depleted force. So you can imagine there was some resistance,
there was some middle management and executive staffers like,
why are we doing this? We're not supposed to be doing marijuana work.
It's drugs. Wah, you cleaning up grow sites chasing bad guys. Um, and Mike said,
no, I believe in you guys, test it,
document it and see what we got to do with this.
And we were six weeks into a three month test program and he is the chief and
all the deputy chiefs had talked about what we were doing out there and we were
now documenting these insane numbers of what was happening. And he said,
we're done. I want it full time by January 1st, 2014 get your testing,
do your interviews, get the protocol. You guys are leaving patrol, you know,
we're gonna have this many spots and you're going to work straight for
headquarters. Straight line.
Kind of like a military special special ops team that just works for the top.
They don't really have boundaries of where they go, you know.
And that's kind of the approach we need and we needed to do a global statewide
approach with no, you know,
hangups to work with whoever we needed to within without of our agencies and
educate and it was really successful and we, but we had to break tradition.
So to your point, we liked what we do because you said it best.
We're making a difference.
Every little grow we get out of circulation makes a difference. But it is,
it's an uphill battle because we know we're not getting them all and we know
it's not going away anytime soon.
It must've been very interesting to talk to the cartel members and have them say
to you that they know that you guys are taxed. Oh yeah, yeah. Like shit. Yeah.
Like they know, they know your operation then like how do they know?
They just, they look at the number and end,
I mean we get so little information because they're so quiet. When you look,
you're talking to them. How many days do you get with them?
We got an interview [inaudible] this was one with DEA and a bunch of other
officials and multiple interpreters and I get to sit in on it.
And it was something that rang Phoebe. Feb wasn't there on that one.
But I do have a, a good Phoebe story for it. Um, many of them actually, but,
but a good one. And it was from that one where a,
she saved that another gun fight from happening. But,
but the thing about it was we don't get to talk to them very often when we do.
Um, it's, it's very rare that they'll talk, um,
they're put together in an organization where they,
we don't really know last names. They only report to one person.
A lot of times they don't know who they're working next to.
So it's compartmentalize, very compartmentalized.
And they do this to make sure that people cannot go back. Exactly. Cannot talk,
cannot reveal very much information.
I know a first name of my boss who's my supplier. So, um,
this was someone that was taken on other cartel crimes at high level,
but not a violent guy. You know,
he was very candid and straight forward and he's responsible for a lot of stuff
in California. And I can say that much, um, and other parts, um, of the country.
But what he revealed was just validating what we knew. But it gave,
it gave us tools to progress and, and learn from.
Yeah, that's what I was going to say. When they,
when you do get that information from him, um, did that, uh,
allow you to get more resources or to like confirm like, Hey, look,
this is what we know. We need to pull out all this infrastructure.
We need to pull out these pipes. If we don't, they're going to come back.
If this is, this is gonna make a difference.
It did. And when we, uh, when we formed it, the new team, we said,
here's how we're gonna approach this. We're going to,
we're going to help agencies. We're going to do our own missions.
We're going to help other agencies that are doing the work,
but we're going to do an under the caveat that we're going to do a three prong
approach.
We're going to apprehend as diligently as we can and catch these guys through
our dogs, through our tactics. Because you know,
just chasing them around and knowing they're going to get away.
There's no deterrence in that. And yeah, it's risky and yeah, it's dangerous.
But at least I know if I take him into custody, even for a day of five days,
whatever, maybe they're deported, maybe they're not.
That's one really skilled guy doing a lot of environmental damage that's at
least out of circulation for a while, right? So that had to happen.
We're going to eradicate every tainted plant and 90% of these grows.
They're all tainted with this Carbofuran. So they have 90% 90%.
It started 10 years ago. It was about one out of two.
And by the time those stats are trickling in at the end of 2018 and is compiling
for the team, I'm like, Oh my gosh, man,
we had Carbofuran in like 89 or 90% of
every gross site we went into wow. On, on these trespass grows.
But then the third thing we had to do, um,
and we would only want to work with agencies that agreed is reclamation.
It's going to be dirty guys. We might have to come back a different day,
but give us your helicopter team. Give us some bodies. Yeah.
And it's specific reclamation like group.
Like it's like, it seems like you should have an agency that does this.
We don't have that in place yet. And this a,
an original Creek that you guys had in 2004 did you guys read divert the water?
We did. And so he gets all the, we actually can't or flowing again. Yeah.
I took two years to get the fish back on that one.
And that was literally what a numbers of fish do you guys think you lost in
that? Oh man. I mean the, the,
the steel header federally listed right now and they're valued at like 20 to
$30,000 a fish. Yeah, they're so threatened. So catch and release of that.
I wanted to ask you as a game warden, you know, not a fan of catching early.
Don't like the catch and release. Well it's weird.
Like I like fishing for food, right? I mean it's like a,
I don't want to shoot a deer with a blow dart either and just go look,
I got one high and then let them like wake up Jesus and get outta there. No,
I'm getting it for food. Yeah. I mean look, I know steelhead fishing is fun.
I know it is. It looks, it looks awesome. I've never caught steelhead,
but I've got salmon, I've caught trout and they're amazing. Sure.
The gorgeous fish.
But the catching them and shoving a hook in their head and then letting them go
just seems stupid. It's not, yeah,
it's counterintuitive to you don't eat them in all patient groups.
Steelhead at all. Well, if they're listed and they're so threatened,
the way to keep steelhead fishing going, you know,
like in California is okay guys, you can catch him, but you got to release it.
That's so stupid. You know? So now what about Oregon and Pacific Northwest?
Are they, do they keep them there? In some places they do.
It's just good eating fish. Yeah. Yeah. It's a rainbow trout, right? Yeah.
Derivative or, but it's, but it's spawning is coming from the ocean.
It's going up river. It's spawning going back to the ocean.
So that's what makes it a steel head know. And uh,
it's an awesome fish and this parents didn't fight like crazy and it's just,
they do really natural. They're tough. Um, yeah. And,
and you just look at the,
you look at how sensitive they are and in that one Creek, in the 2004 grow,
that was the worst scenario that could have happened, right?
That they hit the headwaters of the start of this spawning channel that went to
a Creek called coyote Creek that actually went all the way into San Jose to the
South Bay of the ocean.
So that pollution situation from those band poisons was just decimating,
you know, three to five miles a Creek. So we had to take that water away,
diversion out. We had to clean it all up. How do you clean it up? Net it up,
bag all the trash, pull all the water lines, you know,
what about the pesticides? How do you clean that up? If it's, if it's banned,
we gotta basically get a hazmat team to pull it out. You know,
we got to put it in hazardous material buckets, cap it real carefully, you know,
and then, and then just get it out safely.
And what about the stuff that gets into the ground? You've got to move,
remove the soil. You've got to go through. And we can always do
that. And something that's interesting and um,
we get into this especially in book two, is there's a group called IARC, um,
at a UC Davis, dr maraud, Gabriel and his colleagues,
and they're going in as an NGO and they're the scientists that really validated
the devastation these, these band poisons do. When, uh,
the Pacific Fisher that was almost completely wiped out as a threatened species
in California was linked to DTO grow poisons.
And that kind of came to surface about five or six years ago.
And then the kind of the light bulb went off that, Hey,
this is an outside scientific group of an NGO,
a nongovernmental organization that's working hand in hand with California
department of fish and wildlife and us forest service.
But they're showing the devastation of this stuff in the soil and in the water.
We'll after the grows eradicated, it's not just, you know,
in and around the plants what's going on. So some of these sites,
if you don't do a com a complete, you know, soil over haul and you know,
get all that lining out of the creeks,
it's not going to be completely a completely restored.
And sometimes that can take, you know,
we might have the resources to get back in there for a year or half a year.
We always try to get it before the end of the year when the rains come.
But it's not always possible. It just can't, it can't happen.
And you were saying that these pesticides dissipate off the plant somewhat.
Some ways of time.
Does that the case with groundwater and in the ground as well?
They dissipate toxicity somewhat everywhere,
but they don't dissipate to the point where they're not harmful on some levels.
So is a case in point. Um, I have a slide,
I show my PowerPoint that actually came from IARC and we've seen this multiple
times of, you know,
you have a scientist and he's in the big rubber nitrile gloves, the long sleeve,
the face protection, the hat,
and he's got a gray Fox carcass that right next to a plant in the soil that he
ingested this stuff right on, on a, on a tainted plant.
And the Fox died within minutes.
And then there's a golden Eagle that comes in after and it could have been days
after, we don't know, you know, and their, their carry on feeders, right?
So the golden Eagle lands starts just picking just on the surface,
on the body of this doesn't even get into the carcass.
And here's a dead golden Eagle in the photo right next to the, it's like, man,
just put a radioactive time bomb in that animal. I mean, that's a lot carcass.
And that was days after, you know, when the scientists are coming back in. So,
um, dissipated or not, it has its effects. We see that, uh,
in California with a rat poison and yes, an Eagle or an eat,
not Eagles, owls as well. Very much so. Yeah.
That's why getting all those toxics,
even the ones that are illegal out of areas where owls or any type of Raptors
or, you know, carry on feeders compete too. Don't like coyotes. But boy,
that's the best way to keep those Roden things under control as coyotes.
It's a balance. Yeah, it really is part of the cycle. I mean,
I know people love their little dogs and cats and stuff, but you know,
I was having a conversation with a friend of mine about it and I was like,
you need those things, man.
Those coyotes are important as gross as they are little criminals and little
criminals, the neighborhoods, little criminals in the neighborhood. But man,
you hit it that you got to have that balance, you know, and, and,
and like we all say on the conservation model,
everything needs a little bit of hunting control. Yeah. You know, it does.
The coyotes need it when they're overpopulated, you know, um, you know,
you say it many times, uh, in the message with your guests. Um,
people need to understand that we're helping wildlife as hunters,
as conservationists.
We're helping keep what we have and there's no way we can not manage them
because we've already developed so much and taken so much wild space. Right.
And we've encroached and we've had, you know, a population of mountain lions.
It's ebbed and flowed and climbed. And we've had this and we've had that.
So yeah, we have to be involved. Um,
but this particular problem that we're facing has so many far reaching effects
that we don't even see. Um, you know, as a Hunter, it's just disgusting
counter intuitive to people that may be animal rights activists or vegans that
hunters are responsible for.
The reason why we have such large populations to these animals and wildlife
protection and how much money comes from hunting tags and then recreational
firearm sales. I mean,
that's really the majority of the money that goes to preserve these wild lands
and keep these animals alive. And when you tell that to animal rights,
people are vegans, they panic, right? He's like, listen,
the reason why these animals exist,
the reason why they're protected is because people hunt them.
Exact sounds so counterintuitive. But w you know,
you were talking about Rocky mountain elk and the Rocky mountain elk Federation
has done an amazing job. Amazing, really repopulating areas.
Like now they have successful populations in places like Kentucky where they
were eradicated at one point in time they had been extra painted.
And because of it, not because of us,
because of market hunting back in the turn of the century, right.
The 18 hundreds when people you know,
needed food and they didn't have refrigerators.
So you would shoot something and it was only good for a few days and they would
go out and shoot some more and they would sell that food and that food was these
wild animals and there was completely unregulated hunting. Yeah,
just hammered them. Yeah, it's hard. It's horrific.
I mean we know about it with the Buffalo cause we've all seen those horrific
photographs of mountains of skulls and yeah. But I mean,
that was the case with antelope and deer and they've done such an amazing job
that now there's more deer in this country than there were when Columbus was
here. Yeah. He didn't know he was never here.
It's interesting when you bring up elk because of a, you know, being a,
a worldwide Hunter myself and doing it for so long. Um,
I've never taken an elk myself,
but I've been on these amazing elk hunts where I've guided, you know,
people really deserving of getting their first elk as an example.
And you'll like this story being a fellow, a, you know, an elk guy. Um,
we had a tag in Santa Clara County that was for one bowl for a Tulio elk.
And one thing we have in this,
this state of specialty is we have some of the best Tulia elk on the planet.
You know, there are beautiful, you know, smaller species and, you know, great.
Just, just a beautiful animal. And, um, I saw this tag up, you know,
for, for residents or non-residents,
it was only one tag but nobody would put in for it because all our Tulio elk are
on private land and no one has access. So this uh,
this gentleman true this tool ya'll tag, um, Mike [inaudible] is only one tag.
We give one tack. Why just cause limited numbers.
We know it's going to be a private land, small herd.
We don't want to take too many bowls and,
and we also know that it access is going to be hard. So they,
they experiment with one tag. And uh,
this gentleman that drew the tag was a 70 year old master Hunter education
instructor, one of our top instructors for like four years.
So he's teaching Hunter ed like we do in the Lord in front.
He's paying it forward, draws this tag.
He had drawn it in a similar County in Alameda County the year before and could
never get to any access to harvest as elk.
So I get a call through the Hunter education program, like, Hey man,
I know you know all your ranchers and friends there in Santa Clara County.
Do you have a ranch that we could set them up on? I said,
I'll work something out. This guy's awesome. I mean,
how many future conservationists is he raised up? Um, so I found him a spot,
you know, a rancher, uh,
me and my sister and family grew up with and he had a little,
little cattle ranch, but he had a beautiful herd, you know, he did good,
have heard like four 40 animals and some nice bowls, couple monsters. Um,
so we got him set up to harvest one of those bowls, you know,
before he was too old to do it with this tag. And we had four generations there.
Joe was great. We had Mike, his son, his grandson, and his great grandson.
Oh wow. And I just have never seen that. And then I'm helping, you know,
guide him with the ranch owner and what we thought was the bull.
We've been watching for months, you know,
in all our scouting was gonna be a fairly, you know, not a super difficult hunt.
It turned out to be an all day affair. Of course, typical hunt, right?
Murphy's law kicked in, he was high and on another part of the ranch,
end of the day he gets this bull and it's just this magnificent feeling.
You know, he had worked hard,
he had paid it forward and in the whole hunting world through Hunter education
and we did an article and photos where we saw four generations with this
beautiful Tulio elk in our, in our a Hunter education magazine.
And I have that picture, you know, to this day I just look at it and go, man,
this is what it's about. This is awesome.
Then the following year we got a that same tag and the 17 year old daughter of a
San Jose police detective friend of mine drew it and she had been hunting with
her dad, deer antelope doing her thing. You learn in a hand load like,
like dad taught her doing it all and she had never shot an elk yet.
And so we did the same thing. I took her and her dad and you know,
we had a impact on one of my buddies from the Santa Clara met team Hunter.
You'll read about him in book two. He's a big Hunter as well in an elk guy.
So you know, he was in that circle.
So we all did it as a big kind of family affair. Same things year before,
what should have been a fairly, you know,
a couple hour hunt turned out to be an all day affair. And uh,
we ended up getting her a nice, nice five by six bull at the end of the evening.
And he was excellent, you know. Oh, it's the best ever. People don't know.
We're lucky. It's not commercially available folks. Lean healthy best.
Yeah. Delicious. Yeah. But, but seeing people like
that, you know, harvest an animal they never had access to, it's just amazing.
Um, and then unfortunately that tag got,
got eliminated in our department and I've been pushing with our wildlife
management side to bring that tag back, man. Get,
give people a chance show that we can still do some cool hunting of a
magnificent, you know, elk species here in California cause it's here.
They're just cool. Yeah. Um, I mean,
hunting in California is so unusual to begin with, right?
Because we have these big population centers like San Francisco and Los Angeles
and most people don't hunt. There's less than,
I think it's below 1% now for the entire state.
We're becoming a nonconsumptive state when it comes to conservation.
Um,
to the point where our agency is having to deal with more input and impacts from
non consumptive users of the outdoors. And that's sad to see. You know,
it's one of the reasons why I love California and I'm here all the time doing
business, but I'm a Montana resident now, you know, the, the wide open spaces,
the mindset, gorgeous up there, the conservation, you know,
kind of mindset and no ding here. It's just, it's a different,
it's a different vibe, you know? And that's, well, it's a Hunter friendly.
Exactly.
Very much Hunter encouraged because you're kind of the oddball if you're,
if you're right, well it's people, it's part of the tradition.
It's people's way of life up there for so long that it's not unusual.
And then the population numbers are low and there's so much rural area,
it just becomes, and you know, you could,
I mean I was there just two summers ago with my family and we spotted a hundred
herd, a hundred strong herd of elk. That's magnificent. Hold over.
Luckily I had vine, I was in the car,
I had the kids looking out the window there was screaming and freaking out.
They couldn't believe it. Cause if you never seen, you know,
we see a deer occasionally in California, our neighborhood, we'll see deer,
but see a hundred [inaudible] see a hundred in that country and just gorgeous
green grass and these animals just hanging out there and you know,
it was in the summer. So none of them even have their antlers are just chilling.
It's incredible. Pretty wild. It's incredible.
And it's funny you mentioned your kids, cause I,
I see it with the nieces and nephews, you know, and all the,
all the youth I educate in Hunter ed and just to see that go to grizzly Island
and see a Tulio elk for the first time or anything, they're just like,
what is that? Yeah. I don't know what that animal is. Giant deer deer.
Did I see that in a, some animation Pixar movie? Is that real? Well,
when you see when in real life, when you see when scream. That's, that's,
that was to me, I was on man the first time I went elk hunting,
my friend cam Hanes took me to Colorado and that thing was screaming.
It was just, we were pretty close. I mean it was like within 15, 20 yards.
Like that is insane that that animal can make that noise.
I just got a bugle at for contact us and it's felt as breath. That's, yeah.
It doesn't get any better than that, but it's just such a magnificent creature.
Yeah. Um,
what kind of an impact has your book and your books, uh,
have the, has it had, um,
on policy and people recognize it that this is a big issue and of,
of hopefully change, you know, it's, it's been, um,
we were, we were, you know, hopeful that we'd hit get a big reach,
especially with book two and being retired.
I can speak a little more freely and, you know, go more national. I mean,
obviously when I was working agency,
you gotta be careful what you say and everything's are very,
very stringently looked at. Um, but it, but it's been really good,
um, because it hasn't just played to, you know,
the audience I normally work with conservation and tactics and law enforcement
and hunters and outdoors men and women. It's,
the cannabis community is really behind this book. I mean, they're promoting it,
you know, they're, uh, you know, should flash it on their Instagram page.
I mean, the Northern California growers actually look at the met team.
They had a term that, that a couple of grower, um,
colleagues kind of coined about two years ago and they said,
you guys are earth warriors. This is amazing. I like it. And I went, Oh man.
And you know,
a special ops law enforcement team called earth warriors in California.
And I went, it's accurate. That's bad ass. It's very accurate. And, and it,
it just shows you that, you know, you're, you're not this rigid,
tactically oriented stereotypical cop. Right. You know,
we're out here for,
while I've waterways and in something that I'm doing with hidden war,
especially in book two is I look at it as three-prong, you know,
first thing I got to do is protect everybody. I can, you know, um,
and I can do a lot more by talking and being on venues with you on stuff like
this. Then I can push in a rifle anymore or, or pushing the team,
I can do more for the team or for the agency by outreach that they can't
necessarily do. So that's, that's a blessing and that's awesome.
And then the first, besides protecting, I wanna inform, you know,
I want to be able to tell this story. I mean,
I've been doing this for 10 plus years. I never get tired of it.
I do a presentation where you and I talk about it. I get the chills,
I get fired up.
I feel it doesn't matter who I'm talking to you I could talk to 10 people or you
know, have been in groups of thousands. It's the same. I get fired up. I can't,
I'm unlucky to be able to tell the message. Um, given what we've learned,
I feel like it has, it has an impact. Uh, so, so yeah, we are,
we are getting the reach out there much further quicker right now.
Has it changed policy? Maybe? You know, it's a little too early to tell.
I think it's going to have some effect from the standpoint of when we start to
see the nonconsumptive users as enraged from on the issue as well,
you know, equal to or you know,
mimicking what you and I as conservationists or you know,
people that that are consumptive users.
That's the third part of my approach is protect, form and then unify.
I think we need a documentary. We got something like that coming up.
Do you really? We got something like that coming up and I, and I can,
that's like that. That changes things for people. Positive or negative,
even when they're an inaccurate,
you hear all sorts of rumblings about things after a good influential
documentary comes out. We're actually, um,
it's cool you brought that up because I'm co-producing with a very good
independent filmmaker named Lou Doris, a film called altered state.
And this one's been in the works for about a year and it's, uh,
it's actually gonna be going to be network and distributed through a new,
it's called planet cannabis entertainment network. And they're a,
they're a new channel planet cannabis entertainment network.
They got 40 million viewers. They're doing main content like other channels are,
but they're also doing some, you know,
some funded independent projects and this is one of them. And the nice thing is,
the reason we're agreeing to do it with them is there's no content control,
you know, issues. We're going to get to tell an objective story, not biased.
We're going to tell, you know,
we're going to be embedded with legitimate growers that we've worked effectively
with all on the environmental issue. What are the environmental impacts?
What's working, what's not working with regulation?
Now what do we need to do to regulation to fix it?
We're embedded with law enforcement teams again doing the work, you know,
I've done with the team and telling their story and um,
we're in production currently, so this is,
this is going to be a cool process and I'm going to be involved and on the
ground and you know,
working with Lou to narrate it and interview folks and I'll be back in the
field, you know,
all throughout the state for the next couple of months and beyond.
That's awesome. Well, John, let me know when that comes out and sure.
Willing to let people know,
please do on my Instagram and Twitter and all that jazz. That'd be awesome.
Thanks Joe. And thank you. Thank you for everything that you've done, man.
I mean it's, it's, it's amazing.
And thank you for sharing this story too because if I had not listened to that
Steve Rinella show, I would have no idea. Yes.
I had to only heard my friend talk about that one grow up that they found,
but there was no one there and I would never have known there's gunfights and
all this crazy shit that you guys are dealing with. Yeah,
Stephen was great because he, he thought you'd like, like the story too. And,
and I, I love your show and I got to give a, I like how a killer,
Mike gave a couple shout outs on a previous show. So if you'll indulge me,
I'll give a couple shout outs here in a minute.
But one of the things that I always liked was how you approached this whole
issue, you know, and how you came into it.
Not being a Hunter early on in your life,
all life and you come into it fairly later in life, but just connected,
you know, and,
and coming from such a broad demographic of listeners that are sometimes out of
out of my world previously.
So thank you for your doing and this will be really cool because the guys
immediate or saw it too and, and they, and they, uh, you know, to,
to be able to connect here with you is really cool. And Hey,
the more we can do the message of better, right? Yes, for sure. My pleasure. So,
um, please one more time. List the books, tell people where they can get 'em.
Um,
you can get both books had more as a new one or in the woods as the first one on
Amazon. Um, you can also get updates on my website,
just John norris.com and it's N O. R. E. S. it is not Chuck,
not Chuck uncle Chuck brother from another mother. Yeah, he's in a RIS. Um,
but yeah,
you can also hit me on Instagram and follow for all that stuff besides my
website. It's just J, O, H N NRES. And I do put this out there.
If people want to email me directly and they want a signed copy of the book or
they have questions and since mediate or another podcast,
I get so many people wanting to be game wardens now coming out of the military,
little kids growing up. And I've been nonstop on that since, since Steve show.
That's amazing. So we're, we're, we're getting more people out there, but um,
for a quick, you guys more money.
We're working on it, man. Yeah. Hopefully someone's listening to this. Yeah.
Thanks for the sentiment. But, uh, I gotta give a shout out to, uh,
Blake B and Brian and Blake's here in the green room with me now and I got to
give them credit for, uh, tuning me into your podcast. They're big friends,
so thank you guys. And I'm also doing a, a,
I'm doing a cool custom knife with a Mike Bella camp at a V knives and we're
making the trailblazer custom folder. It's like the dream knife Joe,
that I never had 30 years on ops, but it's an everyday carry. So, um,
some stuff there. And, uh, being an elk Hunter, you'll appreciate this. Um,
I'm doing some pretty cool stuff with axial precision rifles.
There are long range rifle company in Idaho. They're just amazing.
And my partner,
Terry Hewitt and I are running that new 300 PRC for everything from long
distance from our tactical experience target shooting, but also a good hilt gun.
And that's, that's gonna kind of become my, uh, my new elk platform. So cool.
So this is all connected to, you know,
because of this your effort that you put out all this,
all these pieces are falling into place. Yeah. And these and these groups are,
um, it's not only about good product, you know,
but it's about them sending the same message and they are endorsing the book.
They're getting that message out. And a lot of these groups that are,
that are product sponsor or anything didn't know it. Most people didn't.
So that's, that's one of the really, really cool things.
And my publisher caribou publishing, and this is interesting, you'll,
I think you'll appreciate how this kind of comes together,
but Henry Wu and my friends over at a recoil magazine and gun digest and caribou
and blade showing blade magazine,
they're all the same entity and this book with caribou publishing was a step
out,
an expansion book of national issues related to things they hold dear coming
from a gun publication, you know, and written objectively not against cannabis.
So it was really a, you know, it didn't seem like the right fit,
you know when you look at it from the outside, but it was perfect. You know,
everybody wants the same objective, right?
They want safety and for sure anybody who cares and loves about loves wildlife
and these wild lands, they don't want this to continue.
They want this to be cleaned up and we've got to find a solution.
We do without you guys, without boots on the ground,
there is no solution. None at all, none at all. And like I said,
we keep unifying and we hope to just get more message out there and we'll get
some changes all day. At a time, buddy. Thank you, brother. Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it, buddy.